begged begged begged begged
begged begged begged
begged begged
begged
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
hallo
es test es frunzt windows hat nichts an den sound settings geändert das auch mal
was und ist das immer random einfach umgestellt und man weiß nicht warum
So.
Was du warst am Hauptbahnhof.
Aber lass mich mal kurz lesen.
Hey Max, ich musste letzte Woche oft durch den Hauptbahnhof fahren.
Mir ist aufgefallen, wie viel Verrückter auf dem E-Roller auf den Straßen erfahren.
Ich würde mich das gar nicht trauen.
Ja gut, in Frankfurt ist E-Rote Ampel quasi so ein vager Hinweis.
Man sollte vielleicht mal links und rechts gucken.
Die fahren da alle wild durcheinander.
Was du auch öfters siehst, sind so Gruppen von abgestellten E-Rollern.
Die werden ja irgendwie immer an ähnlichen Stellen abgestellt.
Da hast du dann irgendwie so eine Horde von 20 E-Rollern, die da rumstehen.
und dann kommt nachts irgendein Depp vorbei und schmeißt die alle um
und dann läufst du morgens vorbei und siehst dann irgendwie 30, 20, 30 umgeschmissene E-Roller da rumstehen.
Die sind eh wild drauf, ja.
Die parken auch komplett random am Hauptbahnhof irgendwo.
Letztens erst wieder gesehen, wo sie massenweise abgeschleppt haben.
Letztens habe ich auf Reddit einen Post gelesen
Von jemand, der anscheinend
War so
War hier aus
Ähm, da habe ich einen Reddit Post
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal gesagt
Ich habe einen Reddit Post letztens gelesen
Von einem oder einer
Reddit, von Reddit Postenden
Habe ich einen Post gelesen und zwar
wahrscheinlich war die das erste Mal im
Bahnhofsviertel in Frankfurt
und die hat gesagt,
die war überrascht,
dass dort offensichtlich
hilfsbedürftige Menschen
auf der Straße liegen
und sich keiner dafür interessiert
und sie muss dann wohl
irgendwie Krankenwagen gerufen haben und die haben
auch irgendwie nichts gemacht.
Irgendwie sowas. Da hab ich mir gedacht,
ey, wenn du bei allen Leuten, die random
im Bahnhofsviertel irgendwie auf
der Straße liegen und hilfsbedürftig
aussehen.
Wenn du da den Krankenwagen
rufen würdest, die würden den ganzen Tag nichts anderes
machen.
Klingt
jetzt halt irgendwie brutal, ja, ich weiß.
Aber das Bahnhofsviertel
ist voll mit Leuten, die random auf der
Straße liegen und so aussehen, als nippeln sie
gleich ab.
Das ist da Standard.
Aber es ist,
Man muss der Fairness halber sagen, es ist echt nicht mehr so schlimm wie vor 20 Jahren oder so was.
Oder vor 30 Jahren, ja.
Also vor 30 Jahren war das viel schlimmer.
Oder ich kann mich da auch noch dran erinnern, 2010 oder so war das auch noch schlimmer.
Da hast du random Leute gesehen.
Ich kann euch auch zeigen, wo.
Hier, Maps, Google, Frankfurt.
Pass mal auf.
Äh.
Okay.
Ich kann euch zeigen, wo das war.
Also in einem meiner ersten Tage in Frankfurt
kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Da war ich hier Mittagessen.
Ne, die Katz war heute nicht da.
Hier, an einem meiner ersten Tage, wo ich in Frankfurt gearbeitet habe, da war ich hier irgendwo.
Hier irgendwo Mittagessen. Wo ist denn das?
Göbel
heißt da glaube ich, Fleischerei
Moselstraße, hier da, genau
da war ich
Mittagessen, hier
und hier daneben
ist so ein Waschsalon
komm, wir machen mal Streetview
ja, guck hier
hier ist so ein
Waschsalon
und hier war ich Mittagessen
und dann bin ich hier dran
vorbeigelaufen, an dieser Tür
und da stand
da war ich echt verwirrt
das erste Mal. Ich hab nicht
gedacht, dass es so schlimm ist in Frankfurt.
Erster Tag, läufst da dran vorbei,
da steht hier in der Tür von diesem
Waschsalon
steht hier einer in der Tür
so angelehnt am Türrahmen
mit einer Spritze in der Hand,
grinst dich an, als du
vorbei läufst und haut sich die Spritze
in den Arm rein.
So komplett random
mittags, mittags, 12 Uhr auf der
Straße, ja, da hab ich gedacht, oh, das ist ja doch
noch schlimmer als gedacht.
So, und dann,
und dann bin ich auf dem Rückweg hier auch wieder
vorbeigelaufen, also haben wir hier was zu
futtern geholt, bin auf der
ja, Mahlzeit,
das hat tatsächlich mein
Kollege zu dem gesagt,
so, ja, Mahlzeit,
ist für den ja sowas wie Mittagessen.
Zumindest bin ich dann hier zurückgelaufen
und dann lag
er hier im Eingang
auf der Erde danach.
Und sah happy aus.
Das war so mein erstes
Mittagessen in Frankfurt.
Oder eines der ersten.
Und so schlimm ist das aber nicht mehr.
Also du siehst
aktuell Frankfurt im Bahnhofsviertel
ganz weniges
Gespritze nur noch.
Das könnte aber auch einfach
daran liegen,
dass es nicht weniger Drogenabhängige gibt im Bahnhofsviertel,
sondern die wahrscheinlich sich nicht mehr spritzen, sondern irgendwas rauchen oder so.
Kann ja auch sein.
Aber es ist wirklich deutlich weniger geworden.
Auch wenn du hier hinter so in die Richtung gehst und so.
Ich meine, hier hast du ja teilweise schon...
Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich zeige euch mal hier beste...
Moment, warte mal.
Mal kurz gucken.
Frankfurt.
Frankfurt, Frankfurt, Chiquing, da gehen wir jetzt mal kurz hin.
Also, falls ihr mal in Frankfurt seid und was zu essen im Bahnhofsviertel sucht, ohne Scheiß hier, Beste.
Nicht Pak Choi.
Chiquing, wo ist es denn?
Bin ich jetzt komplett verwirrt?
Ist das nicht?
Ist das nicht hier?
Das?
Hä?
Ist das noch alt?
Hier, das da.
Nee, oder?
Doch, doch, der Laden ist das.
Das ist...
Korean Fried Chicken gibt's da.
Was ist das jetzt?
Vielleicht ist das Bild einfach nur...
Ne, das Bild ist... Vielleicht ist das Bild noch alt.
Keine Ahnung. Gab's nicht. Aber das ist wirklich das Beste.
Ihr solltet allerdings nicht hier hinten rumlaufen.
Weil hier hinten...
Weiß nicht, ob man's sieht. Ne, hier ist grad nix.
Hier sitzen immer die...
Die Spezialisten rum.
Ja, guckt da hier. Da sind sie schon.
Und generell würde ich euch auch abraten...
Vom Hauptbahnhof hier vorne lang zu laufen.
Warte mal hier, wir sollen mal ein bisschen hinter...
Also das hier geht noch, ne, Kaiserstraße und so, alles kein Problem.
Früher war das ganz, ganz schlimme Ecke, so in 80ern.
Mittlerweile ist da Copy-Paste jede Einfahrt.
Barbershop, Goldladen, Supermarkt, so.
Aber hier hinten die Ecke, da wird es dann langsam...
Da wird es dann langsam ein bisschen ekliger.
Guck, da hast du dann hier...
Hast dann hier die Spezialisten auf der Gas.
Oder auch nicht so genau weiß, was die da gerade treiben.
Also hier hinten ist eklig vorbeizulaufen.
Weiß nicht, ob das Zufall ist, dass Scientology auch hier hinten irgendwo ist.
Da habe ich letztens sogar mal einen reingehen sehen.
Hier, warte mal, Frankfurt.
Scientology, guck mal
Gibt's
Die gibt's hier auch in Frankfurt
Und die haben
Ja, die haben so eine komplett
So eine Safe-Wand, guck mal
Komplett, komplett
Stahltüren
Verriegelt as fuck
Da kommt
Keiner rein und da kommt keiner raus
Ich hab letztens tatsächlich mal jemand reingehen sehen.
Das ist Premiere seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Hab ich noch nie diese Tür offen gesehen.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was auch mega nice ist?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es wusstet, aber man kann Google Street View mit WASD bedienen.
Guck, hier WA.
Und jetzt kann man sich hier drehen so.
Ohne Maus.
Ah ja.
Gut, aber genug Frankfurt
Frankfurt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar
Fick auf Sponsor
Naja, und die machen einen großen Bogen
Max, hast du schon über die Jugendwörter des Jahres abgestimmt?
Ich dachte, das Jugendwort des Jahres
wird eindeutig 6-7
The hidden attack on chargers.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Verstehe ich das richtig?
Wenn dein Auto könnte theoretisch eine SSH und einen Telnet Service aufbauen über den Charger.
What?
Warum ist da Netzwerktraffic erlaubt
Über den Chargeport
Vor allem
Was für ein
The fuck, also wie jetzt
User root, Passwort root
Top
Das ist ja geil
Plug in, SSH in
You are root
Geil
Das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht gedacht, dass da überhaupt Netzwerkverbindung über den Charge-Port möglich ist.
Gut, an meinen Charger, also ich habe nicht diesen Charger, aber sollte mein Charger betroffen sein,
an meinen Charger kommt ja keiner von der Straße glücklicherweise so einfach dran.
Aber das ist, das ist schon wild.
Das ist schon wild. SSH über den Charger-Port.
So, wo kann man... Moment. Jugendwort des Jahres 2026. Da kann man abstimmen.
Das Jugendwort ruft wieder zum Voting auf, ja? Und wo kann man voten?
Ja, 6-7 eindeutig, oder?
Ich bin...
Guck mal hier.
Es gibt für alle Gruppen
gibt es
eine feingradige Auswahl, ja?
Aber alles andere 1-3-plus.
Bam.
Digga, ist das jetzt auch kein
Jugendwort des Jahres.
Das sagen die seit 100
Jahren, ey.
Das muss
schon 6-7 werden.
Ich denke mal schon.
Well, Rageback ist auch nicht schlecht, aber
ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
ich glaube, das wird 6-7.
6-7 könnte auch 2025 schon angefangen haben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Bitte noch abchecken.
Hä?
Ah, das wird bestimmt 6-7.
Oder 6-7 hat die Leute mittlerweile schon so abgenervt.
Angener...
genervt.
Was hat es mit gute Käse auf sich?
Gute Frage. Keine Ahnung.
Ein humorvoller Ausdruck
für richtig gut. Stabil oder feiere ich?
Aha.
Peak.
Peak?
Das ist doch wirklich
auch schon, das kommt einfach alles
wieder irgendwie. Maka.
Crash Out.
Ah, okay.
Dicker Yoshi.
Ja, Digga ist schon seit 15 Jahren oder so.
Sollen wir mal die Lillungskiste starten?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich will jetzt nicht in Safe-Mode runnen.
Jetzt habe ich in Safe-Mode gerannt.
Und jetzt?
Ist es jetzt irgendwie kaputt, weil ich es in Safe-Mode gerannt habe?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das Safe-Mode überhaupt macht.
Max, mach mal sehr laut, das Banner ist noch da.
Ne, sehr laut ist vorbei.
Banner war ich bisher einfach nur zu faul rauszunehmen.
Ja.
So.
Sollte eigentlich alles funktionieren.
Oh, ja.
Irgendwann kommt noch Alter wieder.
Ich sag immer noch Alter.
Alter.
Ja.
Aber das war bei mir halt das Jugendwort.
Nö.
Ich bin zu faul.
Das war bei mir noch das Jugendwort
Aber das ist glaube ich komplett out
Ich denke mal
Die ganzen Sachen
Die ganzen Sachen kommen ja random immer mal wieder
Ich warte noch drauf, dass Jojos mal wieder angesagt sind
Wer von euch ist alt genug
Um sich noch an diesen dämlichen Jojo-Trend erinnern zu können
Wo jeder so ein komisches Jojo hatte
Jetzt ist aber nicht so ein stinknormales Jojo
Sondern so eins mit Freilauf drinne
drin.
Nee, Beyblades, das war später.
Diese Jojos mit diesem Freilauf,
wo du dann so runter machen konntest, dann hat sich das unten
weiter gedreht.
Die waren damals aber nicht
so krass wie die von heute.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Entwickelt sich ja alles weiter.
Okay, ich hatte keins, was blinkt, aber da
Gab es welche, die geblinkt haben? Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Und, und, was damals auch.
Leute.
An die Leute, die sich an diesen Jojo-Trend erinnern können.
Ihr erinnert euch doch bestimmt auch noch an...
An Adidas-Hosen.
An diese...
An diese Dinger.
Oder?
Die waren damals auch übel.
Das war so ungefähr die gleiche Zeit für Jojo-Kram.
Okay, der Kerl ist echt dünn.
Buffalo-Schuhe, ja.
Gab es auch noch, stimmt.
Aber diese Adidas-Hosen waren damals auch voll angesagt.
Ist es das?
Keine Ahnung.
Warum assumst du hier einfach irgendwelche Genders?
Geht ja gar nicht hier.
Wobei, habe ich ja auch gemacht.
Hosentragenden.
Ja, Buffalo-Schuhe waren auch so ein Ding.
Da hatte ich aber nie welche.
Das fand ich damals schon blöd.
Und dann gab es irgendwann...
Ich kann mich noch ganz dunkel dran erinnern.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie der Kram hieß.
Da gab es so einen Trend, das waren so Chips, also so kleine, runde, wie Münzen, nur aus Plastik.
Und die hast du aufeinander gestapelt.
Und dann hattest du so eine schwere Münze, die hast du draufgehauen.
Und dann ging es darum, wer die meisten dieser Münzen umflippt.
Caps? Hieß das so?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Kann schon sein.
Ja, warte mal.
Aber wenn ich nach Caps suche, da finde ich
Kappen.
Slammer!
Genau, hier.
Caps Slammer. Ja, genau!
Dieses Ding, dieses Zeug.
Bock hieß das also.
Okay.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ja, das war damals auch voll im Trend.
Für drei Wochen oder so.
Yu-Gi-Oh! habe ich damals auch gespielt,
aber ich blicke ja heute null durch.
Letztes Mal wieder ein Video drüber gesehen,
absolut nix mal verstanden.
Das kommt mir noch irgendwie leicht
Aber da kann ich mir nichts drüber vorstellen
Ja
Ne Magic habe ich damals nicht gespielt
Ah stimmt
Ja diese Säcke
Ja ja die kenne ich auch noch
Es gab schon viele Sinnlos-Trends.
Aber wie gesagt, das kommt ja alles mehr oder weniger immer mal so zwischendurch.
Random kommt ja der Kram wieder.
Also mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn demnächst wieder Jojos angesagt sind oder sowas.
Exek? Ja, das kann sein, dass die Dinger so hießen.
So, jetzt haben wir uralt 90er Jahre Trends besprochen.
Es gab noch so viel mehr Zeug, was mir jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mehr einfällt.
Es gab auch mal eine Zeit, da hatten alle grüne Haare.
Das war auch so ein Mini-Trend.
Es gab so viele sinnlose Trends.
Es gab ja da gefühlt auch alle paar Wochen was Neues.
Im Prinzip Tamagotchis, genau, ja.
Oh, da haben wir mal richtig Ärger gekriegt, das weiß ich heute noch.
Von einem Freund von mir aus der Schule, die kleine Schwester, die hatte so ein Tamagotchi.
Und die hat sich da halt den ganzen Tag drum gekümmert.
Und wir haben der das abgenommen und im Wohnzimmer oben auf den Schrank gelegt,
wo die nicht rangekommen ist.
Und da ist das Ding verhungert.
Und als die Bruder das mitgekriegt hat,
haben wir richtig Einlauf bekommen.
Also Furby und Beyblade,
da bin ich zu alt für.
Ja, das war echt gemein.
Das war echt gemein.
Das gebe ich zu.
Die Mutter konntest du aber eh richtig, also von meinem Freund da, die Mutter, die konntest du eh richtig hart triggern.
Das war so eines der ersten Feministinnen, die ich jemals gesehen habe.
Und die war halt damals, ich meine, das war 90er, ja.
da war das
noch was Neues irgendwie.
So und
die hat dann auch immer
ich weiß noch, die hat
meiner Mutter mal zum Geburtstag irgendwie
eine Sammlung von Büchern geschenkt
über starke Frauen und sowas.
Ganz weird champ, ja.
Das war halt
eines der ersten Feministinnen. Heute
könnte die TikTok-Videos machen und voll groß
damit rauskommen wahrscheinlich. Zumindest
die konntest du übelst
triggern mit irgendwelchen
Wie nennt man das so? Macho-Sprüchen und sowas
Ich weiß noch, wenn du die ärgern wolltest
Das haben wir auch regelmäßig gemacht
Wenn du die ärgern wolltest, musstest du dir einfach nur sagen
Frau am Steuer, das wird teuer
Und da ist die immer voll an die Decke gegangen
Hat sich aufgeregt
Wie man dann sowas sagen kann
Und das ist ja voll frauenfeindlich und alles
Hat den riesen Vortrag drüber gehalten
Und eigentlich ging es uns ja überhaupt nicht um die Sache
Uns ging es ja bloß darum, die zu triggern und zu ärgern.
Hier waren ja irgendwelche kleinen Hüpfer mit, keine Ahnung, Zehen oder so.
Das war richtiger Ragebait, ja.
Das war Ragebait, das war Ragebait, bevor es das Wort Ragebait gab.
Ja, jetzt sind auch alle Kinder irgendwie.
Leider, leider,
Sadge, Sadgetime, leider lebt
mein Freund von damals nicht mehr.
Dem seine Mutter wie immer da getriggert
hat mit solchen Sprüchen.
Sadge, ja.
Ja.
Er hatte wohl Probleme, soweit ich das gehört habe.
Er hatte wohl Probleme mit seiner Frau.
Die hat sich von ihm getrennt und hat das Sorgerecht vom Kind bekommen.
Und das hat ihn wohl voll aus der Bahn geworfen und hat sich umgebracht.
Richtig sad, Gim.
Ich habe das gar nicht gewusst.
Ich hab das erst, ich hab das erst irgendwie, was weiß ich, 8 Jahre oder so später, später gehört, ja.
Oder 5 Jahre oder so später zufällig hab ich das gehört.
Freund von mir aus der Schule.
Somit mein bester Freund von mir aus der Schule.
Also gleichaltrig, den kann ich seit dem Kindergarten.
Ich hab mit dem jetzt die letzten Jahre überhaupt keinen Kontakt mehr, der hieß Nico.
Ich habe mit dem überhaupt keinen Kontakt mehr.
Und irgendwie habe ich vor ein paar Jahren zufällig erfahren, dass er nicht mehr lebt.
Ja, richtig, richtig sad.
Hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ja.
Das ist richtig sad.
Das hätte ich auch nie gedacht, ey.
Dem hat immer alles irgendwie nichts ausgemacht, so, ja.
Hat immer nur dumme Sprüche den ganzen Tag gemacht.
du mit mir zusammen.
Ja, aber so schnell
kann es gehen. Ich hab's am
eigenen Leib erfahren jetzt nicht
so krass in der Richtung, ja.
Aber wie schnell das mit psychischen Problemen gehen kann,
hält man gar nicht für möglich.
Und da muss einfach nur
irgendwas passieren.
Über ein paar Tage
reicht das schon.
Vielleicht auch über ein, zwei, drei Wochen
und schon hast du ein Schlagwerk im Kopf.
Das geht ganz schnell
und das dauert vor allem eine ganze
Weile, bis das wieder besser wird.
Ich hab da jetzt,
also aktuell geht's mir wirklich ganz gut,
ja, aber ich hab da jetzt
bestimmt über ein Jahr dran rumgemacht,
dass das jetzt in dem guten Zustand wieder ist.
Ich hab ab und zu nochmal so ein paar Durchhänger,
1, 2, 3 Tage,
aber ansonsten, im Großen und Ganzen
ist es eigentlich wieder ganz gut bei mir.
Aber das geht schnell, ja, also jetzt
Leute, nicht falsch
verstehen, nicht weil jetzt irgendwie der Übergang so war,
also ich will mich nicht umbringen
oder sowas. Keiner, dass da jetzt irgendwie
Panik schiebt, ne?
Nein, will ich nicht. Bei mir war das komplett anders
gelagert. Probleme in der Richtung
hatte ich nie.
Aber,
wie gesagt, mit psychischen Problemen kann es ganz schnell
gehen.
Und falls jemand von euch
Probleme hat, das muss man an der Stelle jetzt auch nochmal sagen,
falls jemand bei euch
Probleme hat,
ähm, psychische Probleme
welche Art, die ihm sehr zu schaffen machen, dann bringt es in der Regel nichts, zu sagen, Augen zu und durch, das wird schon wieder besser und quasi einfach ignorieren,
Ignorieren, weil ignorieren hat bei psychischen Problemen oftmals den Effekt, also nicht ignorieren ist das Fallwort, verdrängen und ignorieren, ja.
Genau, und das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Verdrängen hilft nicht wirklich, weil verdrängen, das muss ich jetzt vielleicht mal zeigen,
Verdrängen
Beziehungsweise ignorieren bei psychischen Problemen
Ist ein bisschen wie das hier
Hier
Kennt ihr Traktor Pulling?
Das ist so ein komisches
So ein komischer Sport bei den Amis
Wo es darum geht
Soll ich mal zeigen, ja
Vielleicht versteht ihr den Zusammenhang, den ich meine
Das ist so ein komischer Sport
Bei den Amis
Da geht es darum mit einem Traktor
Mit übelst aufgemotzten Traktoren
Und da gibt es teilweise Traktoren mit U-Boot-Antrieben und sowas.
So, zumindest geht es da drum.
Also jeder Traktor, ich muss es jetzt ein bisschen erklären,
dass man vielleicht den Zusammenhang versteht, ja.
Jeder Traktor hat hinten, ihr seht das, guckt, es ist total aufgemotzt,
jeder Traktor hat hinten dran so einen Flug und der Flug, der nimmt Erde auf.
Das heißt, der Traktor, der wird immer langsamer und immer schwerer.
Guck hier, hier seht ihr es.
Guck hier, seht ihr, wie sich der Dreck aufstaut.
So, und irgendwann ist der Dreck so weit aufgestaut, dass es gar nicht mehr vorwärts geht.
So ungefähr ist das bei psychischen Problemen, wenn ihr das komplett ignoriert und verdrängt und immer wegdrückt.
Ja, und das Beste, was ihr machen könnt, ist, guckt einfach mal, was es bei euch für ambulante Stationen gibt, so ambulante Hilfe, ambulante Psychiatrie oder ambulante Klinik.
Da gibt es in jedem, es muss glaube ich sogar in jedem Bereich mindestens eine geben.
Bei uns gibt es jede Menge, bei uns gibt es in Hanau eine, in Alsnau eine und sonst was.
Da müsst ihr mal bei euch in der Gegend gucken.
Und da kann man ohne Termin hin.
Da kann man ohne Termin hin.
Setzt euch einfach morgen hin, morgens hin und gut ist, die sind explizit da für psychische, für akute psychische Ausnahmesituationen.
Und da könnt ihr hingehen und da setzt sich einer mit euch halbe Stunde, 40, 50 Minuten hin und bespricht das Ganze mit euch.
Und da kann man dann auch Soforthilfe-Maßnahmen besprechen, sei es jetzt von irgendwelchen Pillen, die erstmal helfen oder eben auch hier direkt ambulante Akuttherapie und sowas.
Also da gibt es Möglichkeiten. Das muss man wissen, weil, was ich jetzt auch schon gehört habe, viele Leute sagen dann, ja okay, man braucht ja einen Psychotherapieplatz und das dauert ja erstmal zwei Jahre. Ja, das ist in Deutschland richtig für den Arsch, sowas zu kriegen. Du bekommst da in der Regel überhaupt nichts, aber diese ambulante Sache bringt enorm schon mal was.
Hauptsache, dass ihr mal jemand hattet, mit dem ihr darüber reden konntet, der das versteht
Und der euch auch erstmal für die Akutsituation auch ein paar Papillen mitgeben kann
Ihr müsst euch keine Gedanken machen
Und ich würde euch auch nicht empfehlen, den Beipackzettel zu lesen
Weil auf dem Beipackzettel steht halt aller möglicher Random-Kram drauf
der theoretisch mal aufgetreten könnte oder mal irgendwann von 1 von 10.000 aufgetreten ist.
Also ich nehme auch Pillen, das ist mittlerweile wieder weniger.
Glücklicherweise, ich hatte auch keine Nebenwirkungen.
War gar nichts.
Und was für Möglichkeiten es natürlich auch noch immer gibt, wenn ihr ganz gut Geld verdient,
ihr könnt euch auch eine Therapie suchen, die ihr selbst bezahlt.
Das kostet ungefähr 150 Euro pro Therapiestunde.
und für eine akute Phase kann man das durchaus auch mal machen.
Also es gibt Möglichkeiten, aber das Wichtigste ist erstmal, wenn ihr wirklich akut Probleme habt,
geht in so eine psychiatrische Ambulanz, die gibt es bei euch, die muss es bei euch in der Nähe geben,
vielleicht gibt es sogar mehrere, geht da morgens hin, guckt wann die aufmachen, setzt euch hin,
sagt ihr habt Probleme, meldet euch an, ihr braucht streng genommen noch nicht mal eine Überweisung von eurem Arzt dahin,
die sind wirklich für solche Dinge da, mit Überweisung sehen die immer gerne lieber,
Aber es geht auch ohne Überweisung.
Kannst du hingehen, kannst dich hinsetzen.
Und da kümmern die sich drum.
Und die haben auch einiges an akuten Maßnahmen da zur Verfügung.
Was man machen kann.
Da kriegt ihr erstmal Pillen, falls es passt.
Die können euch auch so eine ambulante Kurzzeittherapie machen.
Die meisten haben noch eine angeschlossene Tagesklinik, wo man sich anmelden kann.
Da muss man dann ein paar Wochen warten, aber nicht so lange wie auf dem Therapieplatz.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Man sollte keine Hemmungen haben, zu sagen, man geht mal in die Psychiatrie, wenn man Probleme hat.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass die euch gegen euren Willen da behalten können.
Ja, da müsst ihr euch auch keine Gedanken machen.
Also in Deutschland gibt es keine Möglichkeiten, außer...
Also es gibt keine Möglichkeit, euch gegen euren Willen dort festzuhalten.
es sei denn,
ähm,
ihr seid selbst
gefährdet oder ihr gefährdet
andere. Ja, also wenn ihr da hingeht
und sagt, Alter, mir ist es jetzt danach,
30 Leute abzustechen,
dann könnte es sein, dass sie euch da behalten.
Ja, oder wenn ihr,
oder wenn ihr sagt, sobald ich hier rausgehe,
springe ich von der Brücke,
dann könnte es auch durchaus
sein, dass sie euch da behalten. Also,
ne,
wobei es
in der Situation vielleicht auch gar nicht schlecht ist,
wenn die euch da behalten. Aber ansonsten
müsst ihr euch keine Gedanken machen,
die dürfen euch gar nicht da behalten.
Nur bei
akuter Selbst- und Fremdgefährdung.
Also selbst, selbst wenn
ihr sagt, so, ja, ab und zu
hab ich schon mal so negative Gedanken,
nein, solange es nicht drum geht,
dass ihr gleich von der Brücke springt, kein Thema.
Also da kann ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen,
da hinzugehen, zu gucken, wo es ambulante,
so ambulante,
Kliniken und Stationen bei euch gibt.
Als ihr da Probleme in der Richtung habt.
Einer vergleiche ich.
Ja, ich finde, der Vergleich trifft es echt ganz gut.
Ja, es ist echt so.
Also, ein Problem, was viele Leute haben mit so psychischen Erkrankungen, ist ja, also ich habe da nichts gelernt in der Richtung, ich kann das nur von mir sagen, und das habe ich aber auch schon gehört von vielen, dass die auch Probleme haben.
Also, man stellt sich das Problem tatsächlich oftmals viel größer vor, als es ist.
Aber letztendlich ist ja das, was man sich vorstellt, das, was man eben empfindet und fühlt und sich einbildet.
Also, man hat oftmals im Kopf dann irgendwie was ganz furchtbar Schlimmes, wo man sich auch sicher ist,
das tritt auf jeden Fall ein
und das ist auf jeden Fall das
ganz Schlimme, aber wenn man
mal die Chance hat,
mit so einer, zum Beispiel so sechs Wochen
in eine
Tageslinie oder irgendwie sowas
zu gehen, die meisten Probleme
sind gar nicht
so krass, wie man die selbst
sieht.
Man sieht das bloß
nicht, dass das nicht so ist.
Ich hab ja,
ich hab, also ich kann es, ich kann es,
Ich hab's schon mal erzählt.
Also ich hatte ja beispielsweise richtig harte Probleme,
dass ich mir eingebildet habe,
ich hab irgendwelche schlimmen Krankheiten.
Das ist bei mir, random hat das angefangen.
Ich hab mich ja privat versichern lassen.
Und in dem Zuge hab ich mich mit Krankheiten
und allem Möglichen beschäftigt.
hab das
eingereicht, abgeschlossen, wurde angenommen
ich hab ja nix großartig
ich hab ja nix
so, und nachdem ich das abgeschlossen hab
hatte ich irgendwie
so den Drang
guck doch nochmal die ganzen Sachen durch
dass du nicht irgendwas
vergessen hast anzugeben
wo, dabei, ich hab ja im Vorfeld
schon alles durchgeguckt, ja
aber ich hatte dann irgendwie so ne komische Sorge
ja, guck nochmal
alles ganz genau durch,
nicht, dass du irgendwas vergessen hast.
So, und dann habe ich alles nochmal ganz
genau durchgeguckt
und ich hatte nichts vergessen, kann ich gleich dazu
sagen, ja,
aber ich habe dann so ganz, so ganz
komische, komische
Dinger gehabt, wo ich gesagt habe, ah,
guck mal hier, so
komplett random, ne, also keine Diagnosen
oder irgendwas, so komplett random,
so habe ich dann irgendwie geguckt, ah, guck
mal da, mein Blutzucker,
das habe ich mir damals wirklich eingebildet, müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen. Ich hab dann auf das letzte
Blutbild vom Arzt geguckt, ja,
und hab gesagt, also so ein richtig fettes,
großes Blutbild, reingeguckt und gesagt,
aha, guck mal hier mal, Blutzucker
ist im normalen Bereich,
aber
irgendwie
im
oberen, in der oberen Hälfte
vom normalen Bereich oder so, ja,
was überhaupt kein
Problem ist, ja, also im
normalen Bereich, Blutzucker ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
60 bis
bis 100 oder sowas, ja.
Und ich hatte irgendwie 75
oder sowas, ja.
Und
und da hab ich mir wirklich
eingeredet, ich bin kurz davor,
Diabetes zu kriegen.
Weil ich nüchtern Blutzucker von
75 hatte, ja.
Es gibt viele Leute, die werden mega glücklich über 75.
75 ist nix.
Das ist nicht mal irgendwie
in der Nähe von irgendwas.
Ab 126
hast du Diabetes, ja.
Ich hab 75, das ist nix.
Aber ich hab mir wirklich eingeredet danach,
da hab ich übelst Panik gekriegt.
Ich hab gedacht, ich krieg jetzt Diabetes.
Richtig dämlich, Alter.
Und einfach nur, weil ich mich
mit dem ganzen Krankheitszeug beschäftigt.
Das kam so ein paar Wochen,
nachdem ich den ganzen Kram da durchgearbeitet hab,
hab ich das nochmal durchgeguckt,
hab ich übelst Panik angefangen zu schieben.
So, ich krieg jetzt Diabetes und so ein Zeug, ja.
Und dann, kann ich das auch noch mal erzählen,
und dann, dann hab ich mich,
dann habe ich mich da übelst reingesteigert,
ja, und dann hatte ich dann halt
auch schon übelst, übelst, so Herzklopfen
und alles, konnte nicht mehr richtig schlafen,
bin ich übelst angestrengt,
und dann habe ich mir eingeredet,
dass ich nicht mehr richtig schlafen kann,
muss daran liegen,
dass ich irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, irgendwie einen Gehirntumor oder sowas
habe.
So, daran muss das jetzt liegen, und da habe ich
voll die Panik geschoben, Alter,
richtig hängen geblieben, ja.
Ja, so, das ist, das ist, wie gesagt, das ist aus nichts entstanden bei mir.
Und das ist das, was ich, weil ich meine, das kann total schnell gehen.
Das kann total schnell gehen, ja.
Mal, mal, mal die falschen Sachen ein paar Tage, ja.
Ich hab dann, ich hab dann zwei Wochen oder so, so gut wie nicht gepennt.
Also wirklich so gut wie gar nicht, ja.
Weil ich die ganze Zeit gedacht hab, ich hab irgendwie so einen krassen Gehirntumor oder irgendwas, was das auslöst.
Dann hab ich, genau, dann hab ich noch den Fehler gemacht.
Ich hab gegoogelt, ja.
Und dann hast du natürlich alle Symptome, kannst du auf irgendwas super krasses mappen, wenn du gegoogelt hast.
Googeln ist übrigens auch eine sehr schlechte Idee.
Wenn ihr so Gesundheitsängste habt, ist Googeln eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Also seid ihr immer kurz vorm Abkratzen.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste, also das Witzige daran war?
Ich hatte bei, also als ich gegoogelt habe, du findest ganz viele Sachen bei Google,
also Symptome, so nach dem Motto, ey, in zwei Wochen bist du tot, so nach dem Motto.
und das hat mich aber gar nicht geschockt, weil ich hab mir gedacht, ey, wenn ich in zwei Wochen abkratze, ist doch egal, dann juckt mich das alles nicht mehr.
Was mir übelst Panik, wo ich halt übelst Panik geschoben hab, ist, weil ich hatte halt zwei Wochen richtig Probleme zu schlafen, ja,
und nee, nee, nee, Google ist, wenn du Gesundheitsängste hast, ist Google mit das Schlechteste und Schlimmste, was du machen kannst,
Weil du findest halt zu so generischen Symptomen, findest du halt alles. Wenn du beispielsweise sagst, ich kann schlecht schlafen, google mal danach Gehirntumor oder whatever. Also ich würde auf gar keinen Fall googeln. Das ist das aller schlimmste, was du machen kannst, googeln.
Chat-GPT fragen oder sowas, das ist das aller, aller Schlimmste, ohne Scheiß, wenn ihr da euch Gedanken macht wegen Gesundheitsproblemen, googelt auf gar keinen Fall und fragt auch nicht Chat-GPT oder sowas, geht zu eurem Hausarzt und redet mit dem oder irgendwas, aber nicht googeln, ohne Scheiß, nicht googeln.
So, zumindest ging das dann bei mir weiter.
Ich habe halt super schlecht geschlafen und alles.
Und ich hatte auch übelst Angstzustände gehabt dadurch, weil ich gedacht habe, ich kann jetzt nie wieder schlafen und sowas.
Man steigert sich da übelst krass rein in das Ganze.
So, und dann hatte ich das Problem, was ich jetzt ganz lustig finde, das hat ja auch jemand gerade im Chat gepostet.
Dann hatte ich das Problem, dass durch diese ganze Anspannung und Aufregung und Schlafmangel, was ich dann da hatte, hat dann angefangen, beim Einschlafen und so, hat dann mein Arm angefangen zu zucken ab und zu.
Da habe ich so random Muskelzuckungen gekriegt.
Und ich habe ja damals nicht gedacht, okay, das liegt einfach an meinem körperlichen und geistlichen Ausnahmezustand.
Das hat mich nochmal darin bestätigt, ich muss jetzt ja so eine Art Gehirntumor haben, sonst hätte ich jetzt nicht Schlafprobleme und jetzt habe ich auch noch Muskelzuckungen.
Das war für mich der Beweis schlechthin, ich habe einen Gehirntumor.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, richtig hängen geblieben, richtig hängen geblieben, ja.
Und ich hab dann sogar, ich hab dann sogar einen MRT gemacht.
Bei dem MRT kam raus, dass ich absolut nichts habe.
Gar nichts.
Also der hat gesagt, genau so muss ein 40-jähriges Gehirn aussehen.
Gar nichts, wirklich null.
Perfektes Gehirn.
Pfeifhead, ja.
Und anstatt, dass mich das beruhigt hätte.
Anstatt, dass mich das beruhigt hätte.
Habe ich gesagt, okay, okay, dann ist es eben kein Gehirntumor, sondern ein, was weiß ich, irgendwas, irgendwo was anderes, ja, an einer anderen Stelle.
So
Und da habe ich wirklich
Da habe ich mich wochenlang
So krass reingesteigert
Bis ich dann irgendwann
Es hat aber eine ganze Weile gedauert
Ja
Zumindest
das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Irgendwann habe ich dann
bei Google
mal geguckt, wegen Psychotherapie
habe ich auch direkt
was gefunden. Leute, wenn man privatversichert
ist oder den Kram selbst bezahlt, geht das halt
schlimm.
Genau, du hast MS oder irgendwas
random total abgedreht, das hast du gleich gedacht.
So, habe ich
nach Therapie geguckt, wenn man den Kram
selbst bezahlt oder privatversichert
ist, geht das schnell.
und da habe ich da eine Woche später tatsächlich schon erste Therapiesitzung gemacht.
Das hat aber eine ganze Weile bei mir gebraucht, bis das geholfen hat ein bisschen.
Also ja, mir hat das immer gut getan, darüber zu reden
und ich war dann auch danach immer richtig gut drauf, aber das hat nicht lange gehalten.
Also das hat eine ganze Weile gebraucht, bis mich das wieder ein bisschen so die Normalität im Kopf zurückgebracht hat.
Also Therapie ist nichts, wo ihr zweimal hingeht und dann ist gut.
Viele Sachen, die einem da erzählt werden, bringen gar nichts.
Man muss rausfinden, was bei einem gut wirkt.
Die erzählen einem dann halt alles Mögliche, was es dazu gibt.
Aber von 100 Sachen sind halt für euch 10 Stück genau die richtigen.
Das muss man erstmal rausfinden, welche das sind.
Und also was mir beispielsweise bei der Therapie sehr geholfen hat, ist einmal zu wissen,
dass das, was ich habe, diese Symptome, exakt 1 zu 1 wie aus dem Lehrbuch für Angststörungen sind.
So, das war das Erste.
Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, vielleicht hast du doch keinen Gehirntumor oder sowas.
Also jetzt 1 zu 1 wie aus dem Lehrbuch.
Und was mir auch noch geholfen hat, gibt es auch einen Wikipedia-Artikel zu.
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Denkverzerrungen oder irgendwie sowas.
Möchte ich mal kurz Wikipedia suchen.
Wikipedia Denkverzerrungen oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaube, das da.
Zumindest.
Genau.
Genau. Und zumindest gibt es da so ein paar Punkte, wo man sich auch gut wiedererkennt.
Hier selektive Wahrnehmung, Tunnelblick.
Dass man sich so super krass versteift, schwarz-weiß denken und sowas.
Und wenn man das im Kopf hat und wieder mal irgendwas denkt in der Richtung,
und wenn man das dann aber gleich hinterfragt und sagt, Moment Max,
ist es denn wirklich hundertprozentig so, dass du das haben musst?
Und dann fällt dir ein, nee, eigentlich spricht viel mehr dagegen, dass ich das nicht habe.
Ja, das hat mir auch geholfen.
Naja, gut.
So, zumindest.
Das war so mein Problem.
Und das kann ganz schnell gehen.
Du sollst es nicht andauernd machen, nur wenn du mal wieder sowas hast, was dich aufregt.
Ja, wenn du jetzt mal wieder irgendwie was hast, wo dann sagst, hey, guck mal, ich hab jetzt irgendwas Schlimmes,
dann kannst du dir mal überlegen, okay, wie kommst du da eigentlich drauf?
Ist das, wie sicher ist das überhaupt?
Und dann, wenn du da mal realistisch drüber nachdenkst, wirst du feststellen, okay,
eigentlich gibt es da so gut wie keine Hinweise, außer, dass ich jetzt Panik schiebe.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann euch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr solche Probleme habt, nicht googeln.
googelt nicht und fragt auch nicht
ChatGPT
geht lieber, geht zu eurem Hausarzt
oder irgendwo anders hin
und lasst euch das einmal bestätigen
dass das wahrscheinlich nichts Schlimmes ist
ja, ihr müsst aber auch nicht laufen
danach zum Arzt rennen, weil das macht es auch nicht besser
ja, aber das ist auf jeden Fall besser als googeln
Genau, das ist bei vielen solcher Ängste so, weil man interpretiert in alles was rein, macht sich Gedanken über die Gedanken, die man sich gemacht hat und wenn dir nichts 100%ig sicheres im Kopf einfällt, muss das Schlimmste eindrehen und sowas.
Wenn man das mal ein bisschen, wenn man das schafft, ein bisschen mehr von außen zu sehen, wird man sehen, die meisten Probleme sind gar nicht so krass, wie sie einem erscheinen.
Ja, wie gesagt, solche Dinger, macht dir keine Gedanken.
Ich weiß, das sagt man schnell, das hat mir auch nichts geholfen, als das jemand zu mir gesagt hat.
Aber macht dir insofern keine Gedanken.
Ich hatte den gleichen Scheiß auch, ja, Gesundheitsangst und Arm- und Beinzuck und sowas.
Es ist nichts.
Sobald du dich wieder beruhigst, ist das alles weg.
Und selbst wenn das noch ab und zu mal kommt beim Aufregen, weißt du dann, okay,
Okay, gerade wenn man das schon ein paar Mal hatte und wieder weggegangen ist, wieder gekommen ist, wieder weggegangen ist,
da weißt du, okay, das liegt an meiner Gesundheitsangst, an meiner Nervensystemanspannung liegt das.
Und nicht, weil ich wirklich irgendwas Schlimmes habe.
Wo halt aber auch gar nichts dagegen spricht ist, bevor du das alles nur mit dir selbst ausmachst,
du kannst ja noch zwei Sachen machen.
Du kannst mal in so eine Ambulanz gehen, wenn es dich wirklich so krass belastet,
dass du sagst, ich kann nicht schlafen, ich habe den ganzen Tag Angst oder sonst was.
und du kannst natürlich auch mal zu einem Neurologen gehen und sagen, hey, guck mal das und das
und dich da untersuchen lassen und wenn der dann sagt, da ist nichts, vielleicht beruhigt dich das ein bisschen.
Ups, jetzt habe ich irgendwie...
Genau, das ist auch so.
Ja, da musst du den gescheiten Hausarzt suchen.
Am besten ein... also... also... das muss ich jetzt auch nochmal sagen. Also, ich bin ja nicht von mir aus auf die Idee gekommen.
Du kannst googeln, Presarif.
Wenn du keine Probleme hast, dass sich solche Gesundheitssachen übelst triggern, kannst du googeln.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Wenn du dir nicht gleich einmeldest, alles, was du in Google findest, zu haben,
sondern das einfach nur quasi zum Recherchieren über irgendwas verwendest, kein Problem.
Sobald du aber dazu neigst, dir über so Gesundheitssachen krasse Gedanken zu machen
und jedes, was bei Google steht, auf die Goldwaage zu legen, auf gar keinen Fall googeln.
Ja. Also, ich bin ja auch nicht von mir auf die Idee gekommen, ah, ich geh jetzt mal in die Ambulanz bei der Psychiatrie. Bin ich auch nicht von mir auf die Idee gekommen. Ich hab auch gleich gedacht, ey, die behalten mich da und ich komm da nie wieder raus oder sowas.
meine Hausärztin, die hat tatsächlich
ihr Praktikum
oder wie man das nennt,
damals auch in der Psychiatrie gemacht
und die hat mir das erzählt, die hat gesagt,
das ist überhaupt nicht so, wie man sich
das aus Film und Fernsehen vorstellt
und das ist
das Beste, was man eigentlich machen kann
in der Situation, ja.
Nochmal zusätzlich,
die hat mir ja auch schon Sachen
verschrieben
und die hat mir dann auch
einen Zettel geschrieben, wo das alles nochmal
draufsteht und
was da Sache ist, was ich denen geben konnte
und sowas.
Und das war im Nachhinein betrachtet
wirklich das Beste, was ich machen konnte.
Also erstens da
zu meiner Hausärztin zu gehen, zu der Neuen.
Ja, ich bin ja zu einer neuen Hausärztin gegangen,
weil meine alte Hausärztin konnte sie komplett vergessen.
Dass die davon Ahnung hatte und dass die mich
da hingeschickt hat, nachdem wir es dann ein paar
Monate probiert haben.
So, das hat ja bei mir auch eine Weile gedauert.
So, und also was bei mir letztendlich geholfen hat, ist, ich bin zweimal in die Ambulanz gegangen, in die, ich sag jetzt nicht in welcher, in Frankfurt, in die Ambulanz gegangen.
Das erste Mal, also meine Hausärztin hat mir schon einen Zettel geschrieben, was Sache ist, ja, das hab ich der gegeben.
Dann hab ich mit der da nochmal eine halbe Stunde drüber geredet, in Frankfurt.
und die hat mir dann zwei verschiedene Pillen aufgeschrieben.
Einmal was langfristiges
und einmal was für abends bzw. Notfälle.
So, und dann habe ich immer...
Also ich nehme morgens eineinhalb Tabletten
und abends hat die mir gesagt, soll ich eine von diesen anderen zum Beruhigen nehmen.
Aber da bin ich mittlerweile schon runter auf eine Viertel.
Also ich bin gerade dabei, diese Abendstablette auszuschleichen wieder.
Weil ich das nicht mehr brauche.
Ja, und Robin, manchmal habe ich das abends beim Einschlafen auch noch.
Was du da auch beschrieben hast.
Aber ich steigere mich nicht mehr so krass rein.
Ich steigere mich nicht mehr so krass rein.
deswegen stört mich das kaum noch, wenn da mal irgendwie mein Arm ein bisschen zuckt oder so beim Einschlafen.
Da war ich so, okay, hast dich zu sehr aufgeregt und nach fünf Minuten ist das auch wieder weg.
Naja, zumindest hat die mir mitgegeben, ich kann es, wenn wir jetzt schon dabei sind,
wenn ich jetzt schon darüber labere, ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht...
So, weil ich im Chat lese, dass auch viele Leute Probleme haben, kann ich es nur mal sagen.
Ich habe jetzt euch meine Story erzählt.
Also was ich morgens bekommen habe...
Das da?
Das nehme ich morgens?
Max Stahlmann, dann ist sowas hier auch genau das Richtige für dich.
Das wird nämlich gegen Depressionen eingesetzt und gegen Panikstörungen und Angststörungen.
Da können wir den gleichen Scheiß nehmen.
Deswegen würde ich dir auch raten, geh mal in so eine Ambulanz.
Oder geh erstmal zu deinem Hausarzt.
Viele Hausärzte haben davon auch ein bisschen Ahnung.
Die können dir auch schon was verschreiben.
Lass dir auf jeden Fall was verschreiben.
Guck auch, dass du nach Möglichkeit...
Also, du kannst dich...
Ich weiß, gerade wenn man in so einer Phase ist, hat man überhaupt keinen Antrieb.
Aber was sinnvoll ist, du kannst mal googeln nach einer Ambulanz bei dir, psychiatrische Ambulanz. Du kannst zu deinem Hausarzt gehen, du kannst gucken, ob es bei dir in der Nähe eine Tagesklinik gibt und dich da anmelden. Das hat meistens so 8, 9, 10 Wochen Wartezeit. Aber dass es schnell aufwärts geht, kann dir dein Hausarzt auch schon was verschreiben.
und wenn dir dein Hausarzt nichts verschreiben kann, dann kann er dir zumindest eine Überweisung schreiben
und damit gehst du dann in die Ambulanz in der Psychiatrie und die verschreiben dir was.
Und du kannst mit denen mal eine halbe Stunde, 40, 50 Minuten drüber reden, die haben da viel mehr Ahnung.
Und auch wenn das super krass unüberwindbar aussieht, wart's mal ab,
sobald du dann mit Leuten mal drüber geredet hast und die passenden Medikamente kriegst, geht das wieder.
Das einzige Schlechte, was du jetzt machen kannst, ist, wenn du versuchst, es zu ignorieren und gar nichts zu machen.
Ja, alleine, du kriegst das Zeug doch gar nicht alleine.
Ich hab doch gesagt, zum Hausarzt und dann in die Psychiatrie zur Ambulanz.
Das ist doch genau das, was ich gerade gesagt hab.
Du sollst jetzt nicht an Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel gehen und dir eine Runde Sertralin kaufen
Wie gesagt, du kannst ohne Probleme zu deinem Hausarzt gehen
Da schreibt dir eine Überweisung und du gehst bei dir in die, also wenn dir das zu lange dauert, ja
Du gehst in die Ambulanz von, von, ähm, oder von der psychiatrischen Klinik, die bei dir da in dem Ort für zuständig ist
Die gibt es überall, die muss es überall geben
Da kannst du dich mit der Überweisung morgens um 8 da hinsetzen und dann geht das.
Wenn dir das zu lange dauert.
Wenn du denkst, ich halte es noch aus, dann warte bis dahin.
Das ist auch okay.
Man muss sich ja nicht selbst unnötig unter Druck setzen.
Sport hilft auch wahnsinnig gut.
Wobei da viele Leute, glaube ich, das Problem haben, gerade bei Depressionen, sich dazu aufzuraffen.
Zumindest ich nehme das hier.
Das ist natürlich alles, was ich hier mache.
Keine Beratung, sich irgendwas illegal zu besorgen oder so, sage ich gleich dazu.
Ja, nur wenn das euer Arzt sagt.
Also ich nehme morgens das hier.
So, das dauert eine ganze Weile, bis das geholfen hat.
Das hat bestimmt vier, fünf Wochen gedauert, bis ich davon was gemerkt habe.
Und noch ein weiterer Grund, Max, warum es tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll wäre,
mal in so eine Ambulanz zu gehen.
Die haben auch oftmals angeschlossen...
Drücke ich mich so unklar aus?
Das habe ich doch in keinem Wort gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, ich soll euch nichts Illegales besorgen.
besorgen.
Die haben nämlich auch oftmals
irgendeine Tagesklinik
angeschlossen.
Und da kannst du dich auch gleich anmelden.
Und das bringt richtig was. Weil dann hast du
da sechs Wochen tägliche Betreuung
mit allem,
was dazugehört. Also Therapie
plus Medikamente einstellen
plus Medikamente überwachen
plus
alle möglichen Angebote, die es da gibt.
google mal wo es bei dir die nächste ambulanz gibt wo es bei dir die nächste
tagesklinik gibt weil wenn du da richtig krasse probleme hast ist das genau das
was dir was bringt unterm strich
so haben wir es aber genau das dann nehme ich das dann nehme ich nämlich
morgens und
ich hab noch was anderes für Akutsituationen
beziehungsweise
zum Schlafen und für Akutsituationen.
Das nehm ich aber abends.
Und
dann nehm ich anstatt der
einen Tablette, die ich nehmen sollte, mal
nur noch eine Viertel und ich werd das andere jetzt
auch ausschleichen und dann ist es wieder gut.
So.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir das aber.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, was ich jetzt auch schon öfters gelesen habe,
dass das bei vielen Sachen gleich von psychischen Erkrankungen ausgegangen wird.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch...
Aber das A und O ist, einen gescheiten Hausarzt zu haben.
Genau
Exakt das Problem hatte ich auch
Jaja genau
Genau das kenne ich auch
Was mir da hilft ist
So wenn mein Gehirn im Problem
Suchen Modus ist
einmal wirklich gründlich nachzudenken über Probleme, die es gibt oder Probleme, die sein könnten
und dann einmal mir zu sagen, okay, ich habe das jetzt durchdacht, es gibt gerade keine.
Du musst jetzt keine weiteren Gedanken machen, es gibt gerade keine, okay?
Und das muss man sich ein paar Mal sagen, sodass man sich selbst überzeugt davon
und wenn das Gehirn das nächste Mal anfängt, Probleme zu suchen, kannst du sagen, Moment,
Ich habe mir gerade darüber ausreichend Gedanken gemacht und bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, es ist nichts.
Aufschreiben ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe auch eine Liste auf dem Handy mit Sachen.
Das ist auch was, was ich gemerkt habe.
Das muss ich jetzt vielleicht auch nochmal dazu sagen.
Also Probleme ignorieren generell so negative Gedanken oder Probleme, die man im Kopf sich zurecht macht zu ignorieren, ist meistens eine schlechte Variante.
Was mir persönlich wirklich sehr hilft ist, wenn ich daran denke, oh da könnte ja was sein
Ja so irgendwie, oh heute Morgen, nehmen wir mal irgendwas total belangloses
Ja heute Morgen hattest du keinen Hunger beim Frühstück
Und wenn man eh schon zu Gesundheitsängsten neigt, ist es relativ einfach in solche alltäglichen, nichtssagenden Dinge was rein zu interpretieren
So, was ich dann oft mache ist, also oder was ich früher oft gemacht habe ist, ich denke dann den ganzen Tag oder den halben Tag drüber nach, was es zu bedeuten hatte, warum ich heute Morgen keinen Hunger hatte, so nach dem Motto.
Und ich versuche dann auch immer regelmäßig dran zu denken, damit ich es nicht vergesse.
Weil Probleme vergessen ist ja was ganz Schlimmes, denkt dann das Gehirn.
Weil wenn du Probleme erkannt hast oder denkst, welche du hast und die vergisst, ist es ja schlimm.
Weil dann treffen die dich irgendwann und du könntest sie ja im Vorfeld lösen, aber du hast sie vergessen.
Und deswegen ist das jetzt schlimm.
Deswegen erinnert sich dann dein Gehirn immer wieder dran.
Und sagt, ey, da war doch noch was.
Ey, da war doch noch was. Damit du Probleme nicht vergisst, weil Probleme solltest du in der Regel ja nicht vergessen, damit du sie nicht bekommst. So. Und was ich jetzt mache ist, ich hab ein, ich hab ne Notiz, Notizfolder in meinem Notizprogramm für solche Sachen und ich schreib mir diese Sachen einfach auf, sobald ich sie hab, ja.
Ich schreibe mir auf, oh, heute Morgen Bedenken gehabt, ich hatte keinen Hunger, wobei, wenn mir dann gleich noch was Beruhigendes dazu einfällt, schreibe ich auch dabei, wobei, das hatte ich doch jetzt schon ein paar Mal und am nächsten Tag habe ich dann doppelt so viel gefressen, kein Problem.
Und dann schreibe ich das auf und dann hat mein Gehirn freie Kapazitäten wieder, weil mein Gehirn halt immer Panik schiebt.
Ich könnte das Problem vergessen und vergessene Probleme sind ja schlimm, weil dann kann man sie ja nicht lösen, bevor sie eintreten.
Und das kann ich wirklich jedem nur empfehlen, dass durch das Aufschreiben, gibt das Gehirn bei mir zumindest ein bisschen das wieder frei.
Weil es sagt, okay, du hast dir das jetzt aufgeschrieben, das heißt, du kannst das Problem nicht mehr vergessen.
Du hast das schwarz auf weiß da stehen.
Das heißt, du kannst, wenn du willst, da regelmäßig reingucken und gucken, was von den Problemen dann wirklich noch schlimm ist und so.
Also Probleme aufschreiben hat mir aber auch wirklich enorm geholfen.
Warum sind Menschen so verbuggt?
Ja, das ist echt, das ist eine gute Frage, ja.
Und man bräuchte Wim für den Kopf so.
Ja, es ist so.
Stress und Anspannung, Angst zu stellen, macht genau solche Probleme.
So.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber man sollte das mal den Hausärzten, es gibt viele Hausärzte, die wirklich Ahnung davon haben.
Nebenwirkungen können immer sehr individuell sein.
Aber man sollte sich da nicht übermäßig viele Gedanken drüber machen.
Weil wie gesagt, außer mal so ein paar Kleinigkeiten hatte ich überhaupt keine Nebenwirkungen von den Tabletten.
Und die Nebenwirkungen, und das sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, die Nebenwirkungen, die man bei solchen Psychopharmaka-Tabletten kriegt,
die sind eigentlich zu 99%, 99,9% fast immer, temporär die ersten paar Tage beim Einnehmen, als man überhaupt was hat.
Bist du bei der Anfangsdosis geblieben?
Ne, das wurde langsam erhöht.
Ich habe erst 25 Milligramm genommen, dann habe ich 50 Milligramm genommen und dann habe ich 75 Milligramm genommen.
Und das habe ich jetzt seit einem Jahr ungefähr, nehme ich das.
Und das hat auch wirklich was geholfen.
Ja.
Das ist es ja.
Deswegen hilft das auch, darüber zu reden mit jemand, der sich auskennt.
Man denkt immer, man ist der Einzige, der diese Probleme, Symptome hat.
Aber die Sachen, diese Probleme, das ist meistens eins zu eins wie aus dem Lehrbuch,
die Probleme, die man da hat. War bei mir auch so.
Und das hat mich insofern auch mega beruhigt, dass das eben nichts sein muss,
von wegen, ich habe angeblich einen Gehirntumor oder Multiple Sklerose
oder was auch immer irgendwelche bescheuerten Krankheiten man sich so ausdenkt, wenn man googelt.
Sondern nein, ich habe eine Angststörung, die Symptome kommen daher.
Das sind wirklich wie aus dem Lehrbuch die Symptome, die ich habe und viele Leute auch.
Man muss es halt bloß mal gesagt bekommen.
Die Nebenwirkungen, wie gesagt, die Nebenwirkungen sind in der Regel überhaupt nicht schlimm.
zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach überhaupt nicht wild gewesen
was ist mit Libido?
ok, ok, ok
wenn das kommt
ähm
wenn überhaupt ist das auch nur die ersten paar Tage
die ersten 1-2 Wochen
nach der Einnahme
ja das habe ich im Internet auch gelesen
dass Leute, die solche Pillen nehmen
keinen Bock auf nichts haben
in dieser Richtung
das liegt aber, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten
der keine Ahnung von der Sache hat
nicht unbedingt nur an den Medikamenten, sondern generell, dass das Hirn mit ganz was anderem gerade beschäftigt ist, als mit Fortpflanzung.
Wenn du permanent denkst, fuck, ich hab einen Gehirntumor, denkst du nicht an, oh, ich muss jetzt hier mal Kinder zeugen.
und ich kann euch das nur
von mir sagen
bei mir war es die letzten Jahre
ja schon eher so
dass mich das Thema
nicht groß beschäftigt hat
sowohl Familiengründung
als auch so
zwischenmenschliche
Dinger. Ich hab da ja einen großen Bogen drum
gemacht, weil ich zum größten Teil
auch, weil ich das mega anstrengend finde.
Alle zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen.
Aber ich kann
euch sagen,
seitdem
ich die Pillen nehme,
bei mir ist das genau
umgedreht, ja? Bei mir ist das genau umgedreht.
Seit ich die Pillen nehme
und vor allem, seit es mir jetzt halt auch
wieder deutlich besser geht.
Alter, ey.
Ich denke ja manchmal an nichts anderes mehr.
Also, bei mir haben die Pillen eher einen positiven Effekt gehabt, was das angeht.
Oder was heißt positiv? Einen anregenden Effekt gehabt, ja.
Aber das ist aber sicherlich sehr individuell.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist jetzt aber auch nicht so,
dass ich von morgens bis abends an nichts anderes denke oder so.
Aber ich denke öfters dran.
Ja.
Als davor.
Ich kann euch nur von mir sagen,
ich hatte keine schlimmen Nebenwirkungen.
nix. Und das hat auch
sowohl meine Hausärztin gesagt, als auch
die in der Ambulanz,
dass gerade auch bei der Dosierung
und das, was ich nehme und sowas,
dass das Medikamente sind, die sind millionenfach
im Einsatz und das ist
super verträglich.
Das ist eines der verträglichsten Sachen, die es gibt.
Genau. So, jetzt aber gut.
Alter, jetzt haben wir uns aber lange darüber ausgelassen.
Monka S.
Zeigt mal deinen Suchverlauf.
Das ist kein Ding.
Suchverlauf kann ich zeigen.
Ich habe ja einen extra Account für Streaming.
Kein Problem.
Hier könnt ihr euch den Suchverlauf angucken.
Den zeige ich euch.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Suchverlauf hier zu zeigen.
Wobei.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hier, History.
Da.
Nix, nix, nix Schlimmes im Suchverlauf.
Guck hier, Open History Page, zack.
Überhaupt nix Wildes.
Auf der VM.
Warum ne VM, wenn man doch einen eigenen Mini-PC haben kann?
So.
Können wir mal Hannah Montana OS testen?
Nee, das ist irgendein uralt outdatedes Ubuntu.
Kehle abladen, ja.
So, wir müssen GitHub-Trends gucken.
Oh, guck mal, der Hai ist am Start.
Was mir aufgefallen ist im Bahnhofsviertel,
hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr mit der Sache von eben zu tun.
Ich laufe ja mittlerweile fast jeden Tag wieder durchs Bahnhofsviertel in Frankfurt.
Und ich weiß das vielleicht von...
Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht, was ihr jetzt denkt.
Ja?
Also, das sollte keine Überleitung von irgendwas sein.
Ich laufe halt auf die Arbeit fast jeden Tag durchs Bahnhofsviertel.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, die letzten Wochen wieder, wo es so warm ist.
Alter, da stinkt so abartig im Bahnhofsviertel.
An jeder Ecke, Alter.
Boah, das ist so eklig mittlerweile
Das ist so abadisch
Du läufst da rum und auf einmal kommt dir so eine Pisswolke entgegen
Oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen
Boah, ey, ist es so abadisch durchs Bahnhofsviertel zu laufen mittlerweile
Ich weiß nicht, was da anders ist
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das immer so
Aber weil es jetzt so brutal warm ist, verdampft das alles.
Das ist so eklig gerade.
Das ist ohne Scheiß.
Du kannst nicht mehr richtig atmen im Bahnhofsviertel gerade, wenn du da durchläufst.
Und wir reden ja hier von morgens.
Morgens ist es ja nur, in Anführungszeichen, nur 28, 29 Grad.
Oh, was hat neues Video?
Meinst du Kanalisationsruch?
Auch, auch.
Moment, Hannah Montana, Linux 26.
Fuck.
Da gibt es wirklich ein aktuelles Update von.
Debian Live.
Warum gibt es das überhaupt?
Warum ist das überhaupt ein Ding?
Bookmarke mir das mal.
Falls mir mal irgendwann gar nichts mehr für den Stream einfällt.
Gibt es die überhaupt noch?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Also ich meine, wahrscheinlich wird es die noch geben.
Die Schauspielerin wird ja auch erst, was weiß ich, 30 oder so sein jetzt.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wer das war.
interessiere mich da nicht so sehr für.
Keine Ahnung, wie alt die jetzt ist.
Vielleicht ist die auch schon 40 oder so?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Ist sich Taylor Swift das gewesen?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich sage jetzt einfach irgendwelche random Sachen.
Ach, Miley Cyrus.
Okay, okay, ja.
Okay, wie alt ist sie jetzt?
Die ist 1992 geboren.
Das heißt,
2026 minus 1992.
Ah, das ist ja auch schon alt mittlerweile.
Aber nicht so alt wie ich.
34.
Oh, wir müssen übrigens noch Updates machen.
Ganz vergessen.
Reboot.
Ist überhaupt ein Kernel-Update dabei?
Nein, kein Kernel-Update dabei.
Muss keinen Reboot machen.
Jetbrains-Updates vielleicht?
Jawohl, zwei Stück.
Zack.
Der F-Programmer-Kackway.
Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich bald 42 bin?
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Monka W kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Wird bald 42.
Kann ich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
Mit Pan 20 habe ich mal angefangen
COD-Videos zu machen.
AMD hat wohl noch einen Chipsatztreiber
für die Ryzen Generation.
Betrifft mich das unter Linux irgendwie?
Ne, nicht im August.
Aber es dauert nicht mehr lang.
So viel kann ich sagen.
Dann bin ich 42.
Dann bist du älter, ja.
So, hat er jetzt geupdatet?
Ja.
Okay, also.
Was trennt er denn diese Woche auf GitHub?
Schau mal. Weekly Trending.
Es trendet BitChat.
Bluetooth Math...
Nicht Math. Mesh.
Wir sind nicht am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt, Alter.
Bluetooth Mesh
Chat.
IRC Vibes.
But why?
Okay.
So ein Screenshot wäre irgendwie ganz nice.
BitChat.free
Keine Ahnung.
So genau verstehe ich den Sinn davon jetzt nicht.
Bluetooth Mesh Network.
Ist das eher sowas für die ganzen Prepper?
So nach dem Motto, wenn alle offizielle Infrastruktur ausfällt, machen wir Bluetooth Mesh Chat.
Hive Mind Communication. Das klingt nach AI, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Nee.
Okay, AI.
Ich hab da schon einen richtigen Riecher für, was AI ist.
Auch wenn da nicht AI drin steht.
Und ich meine, nur weil Cloud Code dabei ist,
heißt ja nicht, dass das Projekt auch selbst irgendwelches KI-Gedöns ist.
AI.
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Sieht aber auch nach AI aus.
Da kann man 3D-Stells editieren.
3D-Building-Editor.
Okay, im Browser.
Das ist für alle, die sich keinen Bock haben,
Unreal zu installieren oder so.
Aber man muss sich anmelden.
AI.
Geodata-Zeug.
Wahrscheinlich AI.
AI.
Und nochmal AI.
Geil.
Ist ja viel Spannendes dabei.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch mittlerweile richtig nervt?
Ich bin ja jemand, der mega gerne Konferenztalks guckt.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt im Stream, weil die Videos sind halt sehr lang.
Aber ich gucke mega gerne Konferenztalks.
Mittlerweile kannst du 80% der Konferenztalks komplett ausfiltern,
weil das irgendwelches KI-Gedöns ist mit immer dem gleichen Scheiß, was überhaupt nicht mehr juckt.
Und dann bleiben nur noch 20% übrig und von den übrig gebliebenen 20% interessiert dich halt auch bei weitem nicht alles.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt, wenn ich Glück habe, vielleicht 1, 2 Talks die Woche gucken, die interessant sind.
Der Rest ist irgendwelcher belangloser Scheiß, ja.
Also ich habe früher beispielsweise, weil ich viel .NET entwickelt habe, habe ich gerne hier NDC Conference Talks geguckt.
Weil da ging es halt um neue .NET-Sachen.
Und wenn du da jetzt durchscrollst bei den Konferenz Talks.
AI.
Keine Ahnung.
The fuck?
Ich kann jetzt jedenfalls so weitermachen.
WTF?
Wer soll sich diesen Scheiß alles angucken?
Und was noch viel besser ist,
diese Talks guckt auch keine Sau.
Ihr müsst mal gucken.
Diese ganzen KI-Talks, ne?
Keine Sau guckt die sich an.
Die Talks, wo es wirklich inhaltlich um was geht,
haben Aufrufe.
Die KI-Talks, keine Sau interessiert das.
Vor allem ist es auch immer wieder der gleiche Kram.
Ich sage ja gar nichts, dass prinzipiell Talks über KI schlecht sind.
Aber nicht in dieser Masse und nicht in dieser Redundanz.
Also das ist wirklich mittlerweile ganz abartig.
Und du siehst es an den Aufrufzahlen.
Das juckt kaum einen.
Im Vergleich zu den normalen Talks.
früher hattest du vielleicht einen Ticken weniger Talks,
aber dafür ging es halt um Themen,
die was mit Softwareentwicklung zu tun haben,
was nicht KI war.
Und davon konntest du dir halt ein paar rauspicken.
Ich konnte eigentlich fast täglich,
konnte ich auf der Fahrt mit der Bahn
früher irgendeinen schönen Konferenztalk im Hintergrund laufen lassen
und mir das anhören.
Mittlerweile musst du ja da richtig suchen danach,
was Gescheites zu finden.
Ich guck mir ja mittlerweile
schon, wo wir gerade nochmal bei NDC-Konferenzen
sind, ich guck mir
ja mittlerweile schon langweilige
Talks an.
Testing. Hier. Ich guck
mir ja mittlerweile schon langweilige Talks
an, wie .NET-Testing-
Technik. Und wer mich kennt, der weiß,
Tests sind overrated, jebaited,
outdated. Ja?
Wer einfach dafür sorgt, dass seine Software
First Try funktioniert und das Richtige
macht, braucht keine Tests.
Braucht keine Kommentare und braucht keine Dokumentation.
Ganz einfach.
Aber sogar ich gucke mir schon Videos über .NET Testing an.
Weil es einfach zwischen dem ganzen KI-Geschiss nichts anderes mehr gibt.
Nee, nee.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mich manchmal fühle, wenn ich sowas sage?
So.
Oder geht es euch auch so?
Chat, ist das was, weil ich OldmanYellsatCloud bin?
Oder ist das wirklich legit, dass mich das abfuckt?
Sagt mal.
Ich trinke mal natürlich.
Beides, okay.
Stimmt, wahrscheinlich ist es beides, ja.
Wahrscheinlich ist es beides.
Da ist was dran, aber ich bin auch Old Man Yellow Zed Clown.
So.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, was in anderen Sprachen so trendet.
Wir machen jetzt mal was.
Chat.
Also, mal gucken.
Kann man das hier kopieren irgendwie?
Okay.
Pass mal auf.
Ich hoffe, man kann das kopieren.
Wir machen das heute mal ein bisschen anders, okay?
Okay, so, jetzt haben wir alle Sprachen von GitHub.
Okay.
So.
Save as lang.txt
Und jetzt picken wir cat lang.txt.
Wie picke ich am besten eine random Zeile mit Bash?
Bash, pick random line from file.
Wie macht man das am besten?
Gibt es bei Codeberg auch Trending?
Schuff.
Get n random lines.
Okay, top.
Eins.
Aare.
WTF?
Okay, wir gucken jetzt.
Wir gucken Codeberg.
Wir können mal gucken, ob es da auch Trends gibt.
Aber da ist halt deutlich weniger unterwegs als...
What the fuck?
Als auf GitHub.
Gibt es hier Trends?
Filter?
Sort?
Ne.
Hat Codebag sowas wie Trends?
Trending Repositories.
Okay, naja, gibt's nicht.
Okay, also wir gucken...
Was ist Haare überhaupt für eine Sprache?
Okay, also...
Was trendet in Haare?
Äh, GitHub, hallo?
Nix.
Okay, top.
Nächste Sprache.
Er...
Nein, es ist nicht Erlang.
Erlang ist super hässlich
Erlang
Das hier, guck mal
Das ist glaube ich gültiges Erlang
Okay, gibt es da irgendwas spannendes?
Cowboy
Okay, ich zeige euch jetzt
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal richtig
Schönes Erlang an
Ah, yes
Ist Erlang nicht wunderbar
Alter, diese Sprache, man
Grausam, oder?
Ganz schrecklich.
Das hat ein bisschen was von Imex Lisp, so.
Aber ist Erlang nicht...
Ist Erlang nicht irgendwie ein Lisp-Dialekt oder sowas?
Okay, nee, ist es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also Erlang ist wirklich hässlich as fuck.
The fuck, Alter.
Wie viele random verwirrende Zeichen will ich hintereinander machen?
Das ist bestimmt Discard oder irgendwie sowas.
Okay, ich meine, den Rekord für random sinnlose Zeichen hintereinander, die erlaubt sind, hält wahrscheinlich immer noch C++.
Erlang hat doch dieses Hot Reload Feature.
Sicher, dass du nicht Alexia meinst, sondern wirklich Erlang?
Jabber!
Krasser Scheiß.
Das gibt's noch?
Kennt das noch jemand? Jabber?
Das ist ein Chat, damit konnte man chatten früher
Also man kann immer noch damit chatten
Jammer
Alter, dass ich das nochmal sehe
Zu Zeiten, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe
Hat man Jammer-Chats verwendet
Das war gar nicht übel, ja
Genau, XMPP ist das
Richtig, ja
ok da nicht so spannend aber was zum teufel ist höchste müll
dann lernen wir wieder sachen kennen die ich noch nie im leben gesehen habe
wir gucken jetzt noch 34 dieser random sprachen und dann gucken wir mal die die
normal okay da er trennt nichts leyen plant uml
Trended?
Nix.
Aber was zum Teufel ist Plant UML?
What?
Okay.
Ignorieren wir.
Easy Markup.
Gibt es da vielleicht auch mal irgendwas,
was ich schon mal gehört habe?
Gibt's auch nicht.
Easy Markup. Gut, ich glaub...
Ich glaub, ganz so schlau...
Blitz Basic. Ich glaub, ganz so schlau
war das nicht, weil die meisten Sprachen
sind halt einfach dead.
Er trennt
nichts. Das macht keinen Sinn.
Hokon.
Ich glaub, wir müssen die meisten Sprachen da rausschmeißen,
weil's davon halt einfach keine Repos gibt.
Marco.
WTF, wie viele random Sinnlosesprachen es gibt
OpenRC
Okay, QuickBase
Ich mache jetzt so lange random
Bis eine Sprache rauskommt
Von der ich schon mal was gehört habe, okay
IL Assembly
RA Script
GN
Marco, nochmal
OpenQuasm
Sway
MC Functions
Small
Das kenne ich
Weiß nicht, ob da was trendet
immerhin ein ein repo trendet source
baseline of compiler
auch sehr schön lesbar oder
oder?
Sehr.
Sehr hübsche.
Sehr hübsche Sprache auch, ja.
Wie das ausschaut, man.
Kann das irgendjemand lesen?
Achso, es ist Inspired
bei Smalltalk. Es ist noch nicht mal Smalltalk.
Also ich glaube, das hat keinen Sinn. Wir klicken mal wieder die üblichen Sprachen so durch.
4D, BriteScript, PKL, Slice, Liquid Soap.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
World of Warcraft Add-on Data.
Brainfuck, okay. Das können wir mal gucken.
Was trendet in Brainfuck?
Trendet da überhaupt was in Brainfuck?
Dockerfiles.
Moment, warum trennt denn die Docker-Files in Brainfuck?
GitHub, nerv doch nicht rum.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber Brainfuck, Example, Brainfuck ist genau die Sprache, wie sich es anhört.
Guck, das ist ein Brainfuck-Programm.
Das ist halt absichtlich so gemacht,
dass es Brainfucked.
Das ist genau dafür gemacht, wie es aussieht.
Okay, gucken wir mal die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Gucken wir mal, was trendet in Rust.
Wir skippen die Sachen, die wir letzte Woche schon geguckt haben.
Hatten wir schon.
Was ist das? Das kenne ich noch nicht.
Tokio.
So, Tokio hat jetzt ein neues Framework, um Web-Apps zu bilden.
Aha.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht so ganz verstehe?
Was ist mit diesem Trend?
Also das habe ich jetzt bei Rust schon öfters gesehen.
Dieser Wunsch danach, Web-Apps in Rust zu programmieren.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Warum kann man Web Apps nicht einfach in
Kaffa Script programmieren
Backend in Rust
Ja Web Assembly
Aber warum
Also ich kann es ja verstehen
Wenn man Web Assembly macht
Wenn man irgendwelches Interop
Mit schon bestehenden Libraries machen will
Zum Beispiel wir haben mal
Im Stream ist schon 3 Jahre oder so her
Haben wir mal einen Videoplayer
In C++ programmiert
und nach WebAssembly
kompiliert,
transpiled oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag,
der Videoplayer konnte dann im Browser
Dateiformate abspielen,
die der Browser standardmäßig nicht kann.
Das war eigentlich mega nice.
So, dass man dafür WebAssembly
verwendet und so, verstehe ich.
Aber für stinknormale WebApps,
wo ist da überhaupt
der Sinn von WebAssembly?
JavaScript
ist sehr kontrovers. Warum?
javascript ist die meistverbreitete sprache der welt quasi mittlerweile also
wir kommen uns das gleich mal das ist so ganz verstehe ich diesen trend nicht
Ich finde JavaScript nicht schäbig.
Ich finde JavaScript eigentlich ganz gut.
JavaScript hat ein paar verwirrende Ecken.
Aus historischen Gründen.
Aber dem
JavaScript-Gremium
muss man wirklich zugutehalten,
dass fast alle Änderungen
die die letzten 15 Jahre
oder so eingeführt wurden für die Sprache
JavaScript
immer besser gemacht hat. Der NPM ist ja
auch eher eine Node.js Geschichte.
Package, das ist ein ganz anderes Problem.
Aber JavaScript an sich
ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Die hat jetzt keine super umfangreiche Standard-Library,
das stimmt.
Aber das meiste, was man für Web-Anwendungen
so tagtäglich braucht,
ist ja mittlerweile dabei.
Da können sich zum Beispiel die C++-Leute mal was davon abschneiden.
Guckt euch mal an, wie schön man beispielsweise Arrays filtern kann in JavaScript versus C++.
Oder wie schön Async Await in JavaScript ist versus wie nicht vorhanden bzw. halb vorhanden es in C++ ist.
Schön, man Lambdas machen kann in JavaScript,
wie hässlich die in C++ sind.
Also, JavaScript,
wann ging dann dieser ganze
Client-Site-Frontend-Gedöns los?
Das ging los, so würde ich sagen,
so 2010 ungefähr rum, oder?
Mit ECMAScript 5, glaube ich.
Oder ECMAScript 6.
Kann sich noch irgendjemand dran erinnern?
mit welcher javascript version so dieser hat so dieser hype quasi richtig losging
wo dann auch nots irgendwann gekommen ist und javascript auf den server
gebracht haben so was das war glaube ich echt mal schon fünf oder es gibt sechs
so und seitdem seitdem wieder angefangen haben ist die sprache kontinuierlich
eigentlich nur besser geworden c++ ist einfach immer wirrer und
undurchsichtiger und irgendwo auch beschissener geworden mit den letzten Standards.
Also für jedes gute Feature, was sie bei C++ neu gebracht haben,
kamen drei verwirrende Crap Features oder beziehungsweise schlecht gemachte Features.
Echma Script Versions. Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal nach.
version history da war das auf jeden fall script 5
dass das tag war es um 6 ich glaube ab hier ging es so langsam los mit erst 5
Getters & Zetters, Library Support
für JSON. Okay, also
hier ging das so langsam los.
So richtig abgehoben
ist JavaScript dann hier
ECMAScript 6
2015.
Da kam dann irgendwann
Node.js
kam dann hier irgendwie.
Node.js Version History. Das Node.js
ist glaube ich schon ein bisschen älter als 2015.
Node.js kam raus
Ja, hier
Das hat angefangen quasi so irgendwann
2013 und dann
Ja, also Node.js ging auch dann so richtig ab
Mit ECMAScript 6
Oder ECMAScript
Da ging es dann langsam
Ab da, ab hier
War quasi der JavaScript Siegeszug
nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Da kam dann Elektron irgendwann noch
dabei. Elektron hieß ja nicht
von... Chat, wer von euch weiß noch,
wer ist schon so lange dabei,
wer von euch weiß noch,
wie Elektron ursprünglich hieß?
Mal gucken, ob das in dem Wikipedia-Artikel
überhaupt drinsteht.
Atomshell, genau.
Und wer weiß noch, was Atom ist?
Atom?
Gibt es ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Ja, Formal Downloaders Atom Shell, genau.
Genau, der Code Editor von GitHub.
Gucken wir mal, wann die erste Atom Shell rausgekommen ist.
Okay, 2013, ja, alles so in dem Dreh.
2015 zu Elektron renamed.
Atom war, so kurz war das gar nicht.
Atom wurde ja erst vor drei oder vier Jahren eingestellt.
Das Ding war, der war von Anfang an, also der hatte am Anfang halt das Problem,
dass du nur Dateien öffnen konntest bis, bis, äh,
Nicht groß auf jeden Fall.
Keine Ahnung, wie groß die Beschränkung war bei Atom.
Und es hat dann gar nicht mehr lange gedauert.
Es gab dann so einen richtigen Hype um JavaScript-Editors.
Da gab es dann Bracket von Adobe, Visual Studio Code von Microsoft, Atom von GitHub.
Dann gab es noch irgendwas mit Table, wo ich den Namen vergessen habe.
Es gab ganz viele so Dinger.
und
es hat sich dann aber relativ
Supply-Text wurde gerne benutzt
für Frontend
aber selbst ist Supply-Text
glaube ich in C++ programmiert
wenn ich nicht ganz verkehrt liege
genauso wie
TextMate oder sowas, was es davor noch gab
aber
es hat sich dann mit der Zeit
Visual Studio Code
durchgesetzt
und spätestens seit der Übernahme
von GitHub durch Microsoft
war dann Atom
endgültig auf dem Abstellgleis, weil
warum sollen die zwei JavaScript-Editor
nebeneinander fliegen? Macht ja
wenig Sinn.
Ja, aber ab hier
ging es dann wirklich bergauf.
Also hier, spätestens hier mit
Node.js und Electron, alles hier so in diesem Dreh
war der Siegeszug
von JavaScript nicht mehr aufzuhalten. Und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen, JavaScript ist die meistbenutzte
Sprache der Welt, wenn man
nach GitHub geht.
Vielleicht sieht das
anders aus, wenn man
Millionenzeilen Legacy Code
und Business Enterprise Zeug
mit einrechnen würde.
Dann wird wahrscheinlich Java noch eine ganze
Ecke weiter oben sein, als
in dem GitHub Ranking.
Und da werden wahrscheinlich auch so Sachen wie Kobol
noch auftauchen, die im
GitHub Ranking überhaupt nicht mehr drin sind.
Aber ich glaube schon,
dass JavaScript heutzutage
selbst, wenn man über alle Programmiersprachen geht
und alle Projekte ist, JavaScript ganz weit
oben mit dabei.
Gibt es eigentlich
bei GitHub
GitHub Most Used
Languages? Gibt es da eigentlich noch eine
Gibt es da schon von 2026 was?
Naja, für 2025 gibt es was.
Genau.
Ach, wir gucken uns das an, wenn es 2026 rauskommt.
Dauert ja nur noch ein, zwei Monate.
Ja, ja, gibt es auch total, total viel.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich, dass in der Menge ist JavaScript wirklich weit oben.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, jede Webseite, die wir heutzutage benutzen,
und ich sage das mal absichtlich so, benutzt JavaScript.
Ja, es wird einen ganz, ganz, ganz kleinen Prozentsatz geben,
die plain HTML, CSS machen.
Aber jede Webseite mit ein bisschen Funktionalität hat JavaScript.
Also wir haben Milliardenzeilen JavaScript, die jeden Tag verwendet werden.
Da muss ich mal überlegen.
Ich glaube, ich habe letztens gelesen, wenn du heutzutage auf Facebook gehst.
Ich war bestimmt schon drei Jahre nicht mehr auf Facebook.
Ich gehe auch nicht auf Facebook, weil was soll ich auf Facebook?
Aber ich habe gelesen, ich glaube bei Hacker News letztens,
Wenn du heutzutage auf Facebook gehst und noch nichts gecached hast, also wenn du zum ersten Mal auf Facebook gehst, wir können das übrigens gleich mal ausprobieren, lädst du glaube ich 13 oder 14 Megabyte JavaScript erstmal runter, damit die Seite überhaupt richtig lädt.
Wollen wir das mal überprüfen? Bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie wir das gescheit überprüfen können.
Gehen wir mal hier in Network
Wir machen den
Disable Cache
Facebook
Max FPS Facebook
Okay, ich gehe auf meine Facebook-Seite
Wobei ich keine Ahnung habe, ob ich das Login noch habe
Ja, komm mal
Komm mal, seht ihr das?
Und es ist noch nicht fertig.
Facebook ist so ein Schrott, Alter.
Du kannst doch nicht einmal
eine fucking Seite scrollen.
Also 5 MB gezippt
und ungezippt 18 MB.
Wann war letzter Post? 2013 oder so.
Alles krass, oder?
Was für Massen an JavaScript
mittlerweile notwendig sind, damit überhaupt
so eine Seite wie Facebook lädt?
Wollen wir mal vergleichen?
Wenn du auf X gehst,
was die frisst?
Das ist schon mal nicht ganz so krass.
X hält sich ja noch im Rahmen.
Immer noch viel zu viel.
Und YouTube?
Wobei YouTube echt wegen den ganzen Thumbnails
und so auch ein bisschen unfair ist jetzt.
YouTube haut auch richtig rein.
Ich will kein...
Schrei nicht rum, aller OTF.
Also YouTube haut auch richtig rein.
Also ihr seht, mittlerweile ist JavaScript
milliardenfach im Einsatz.
Die YouTube-App fuckt mich in letzter Zeit richtig ab.
Es gibt bei YouTube Premium in der App
so ein Feature,
dass man die nächsten Videos queuen kann,
so wie in dem Musikplayer.
Warum das ein Premium-Feature ist, absolut keine Ahnung.
Ich finde, es müsste Basic Essential sein.
Filter der Adblocker auf Skripte.
Du hast recht, ich habe meinen Adblocker an.
Ohne Adblocker wäre das Ganze noch viel mehr.
Aber es kann sein, dass der Adblocker aus ist, wenn ich...
Ne, der Adblocker...
Okay, Leute, wir müssen den Adblocker ausmachen.
Und dann nochmal öffnen.
Facebook.
Der Adblocker ist nicht aus.
WTF?
Hört gar nicht auf.
Es hört nicht auf.
Es ist sogar noch ein bisschen mehr.
Oder weniger?
Vielleicht, vielleicht ist es, aber jetzt, jetzt ist bestimmt ein bisschen was gecached trotzdem.
Ob da noch jQuery drin ist?
Vielleicht, jQuery ist auf einem Großteil der meistbesuchten Webseiten noch aktiv.
Glaubt man gar nicht, ist aber so.
halbes betriebssystem ganz ehrlich ein browser ist mit der hat mittlerweile mehr
zeilen als wird als ein betriebssystem ich glaube chrome hat mehr zeilen als der
gesamte also der source code von chrome ist mittlerweile größer als das source
code von ganz windows
Und es ist die letzten Jahre eher noch viel weiter gewachsen.
Chrome-Kompilieren dauert deutlich länger als Linux-Kernel.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also deutlich länger.
Linux-Kernel hast du wie in 2-3 Minuten kompiliert.
Chrome brauchst du gigabyteweise RAM, massig viel Disk und es kompiliert dann 3 Stunden oder so.
Chrome selbst kompilieren ist fast nicht möglich.
Okay, machen wir das hier aber mal zu.
Was trennt ihr denn sonst noch so bei Rust?
Minecraft-Server, AI.
Nee, gar kein AI.
Sieht aus wie AI.
Privacy-First-Grammar-Checker.
Ohne Screenshots.
uv das ist für die für die peisen fans ist ja ich hab's letztens ich habe es
letztens auf twitter geschrieben und ich sag's ich sag's noch mal im stream
vielleicht hat ja von euch eine super schlaue idee ich würde gerne öfters
Python benutzen für CLI Tools.
Einfach weil die Sprache
angenehm ist.
Aktuell mache ich CLI Tools
zu 99% in Go.
Weil es halt super
easy ist in Go
Single Self-Contained
Binary rauszuhauen, was
einfach überall läuft.
Aber Python ist schon
ein Ticken, auch wenn ich mich damit jetzt nicht so
wirklich so gut auskenne wie in Go,
ist schon ein bisschen angenehmer zu programmieren.
Was ich in Python bisher mega painstamp finde, ist,
aus einem Tool einen Self-Contained Binary zu bauen.
Würdest du echt sagen, Python größer JavaScript?
Nö, würde ich nicht zwangsläufig sagen.
Ich finde beides nicht schlecht für so Sachen.
Kann man beides wunderbar verwenden.
Aber bei JavaScript habe ich das gleiche Problem.
Ich habe auch bei JavaScript noch keine gute Möglichkeit gefunden,
richtig echte Self-Contained Binaries ohne Dependencies zu dem System,
auf dem es kompiliert wurde und was einfach überall läuft.
Wir können jetzt mal Python und JavaScript hier ersetzen.
Wir können mal beides nehmen.
also sowohl für Python als auch für JavaScript, habe ich noch keine gute Möglichkeit gefunden,
die quasi an die Möglichkeiten von Go rankommt,
Command-Line-Tools als Self-Contained Binary zu shippen, die überall funktionieren.
Das Ding ist, aber selbst da gibt es ein Problem.
Das haben wir sogar letztens mal ausprobiert, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir es in Deno oder in Bun ausprobiert haben.
Das Problem sowohl bei JavaScript als auch bei Python, es gibt ja Projekte, die packagen quasi die Runtime mit dem Programm zusammen,
bundeln das dann in ein Binary zusammen und im Endeffekt, was passiert ist, wenn du das Binary startest, startet erstmal die Runtime
und dann startet sein Programm
drin. Das Problem ist,
dass das immer noch
zumindest habe ich bisher noch nichts anderes
gefunden,
immer noch Abhängigkeiten
oftmals hat zum System,
auf dem du es kompilierst.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du
es gibt
so ein Projekt, das wandelt Python-Code
in C-Code um
und kompiliert das dann,
dann hast du immer die Abhängigkeit
zur GLIPC Version auf dem System
wo du es kompiliert hast
was du dagegen machen kannst ist
du kannst das in einem Container
kompilieren mit einer uralten
GLIPC Version
dass es gegen die neueren geht
ja, aber da hast du schon das Problem
dass es dann unter Alpine nicht läuft
weil Alpine ja Musel verwendet
anstatt GLIPC
und GLIPC selbst
Static Linken ist ja
verpönt. Das heißt, du müsstest
es quasi in einem Container bauen
gegen ein Static Musel Build
und dann hoffst du,
es ist übelst der Pains Champ,
wenn du das Ganze
mit Go vergleicht.
Bei Go sagst du einfach
C Go gleich 0,
dass der gar nicht auf die Idee
kommt, sowas zu machen.
Go Build, fertig.
Und dein Go Binary läuft
auf jedem x-beliebigen Linux seit Kernel 2.6.32.
Selbst mit C Sharp hast du die Probleme, die ich gerade beschrieben habe.
Wenn du C Sharp IoT kompilierst,
dann ist das auch erstmal abhängig gegenüber der auf dem Kompiliersystem vorhandenen GLIB-C.
Du kannst C-Sharp auch gegen Musel
Kompilieren, dann hast du aber das Problem
Wenn du DL Open machen willst
Also dynamisch
Eine Library öffnen möchtest
Geht das nicht
Weil Static gelinkte C-Library
Erlaubt kein Open von
Anderen, also das ist
Super eklig
Also in Go ist es halt einfach nice
Weil in Go gibt es auch, also in Go
Hättest du prinzipiell die gleichen Probleme, wenn du externe
C-Libraries einbinden willst, aber das musst du
in go in der regel nicht ja wenn du sie schafft verwendest und sowas machen möchtest wie ffm pack
dann musst du halt gegen gegen den ffm pack dann brauchst du dynamisch gelingte c library und es
ist aber hat ich ja gut für für command line tools gebe ich dir recht command line tools in
c sharp musst du halt gucken dass du das gegner möglichst alte gelb c version laufen lässt dass
dass es auf neueren Linuxen lauffähig ist.
Oder du musst gucken,
dass du es gegen ein
statisches Musel-Bild laufen lässt.
Beispielsweise unter Alpine.
Wobei das in C Sharp auch
gar nicht so einfach ist, weil
C Sharp möchte beispielsweise
standardmäßig
OpenSSL haben.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch irgendwie abschalten.
Und viel Spaß, OpenSSL
gegen Musel erstmal statisch zu...
Es ist alles so übelster Abfuck.
Also am besten funktioniert das eigentlich in Go.
Ja gut, du kannst die App packagen und dann brauchst du UV, um die wieder zu starten.
Ich rede ja davon, dass du ein Binary bekommst, was du auf eine Linux-Kiste kopieren kannst, starten und gut ist.
Das ist ja im Prinzip das, was ich will.
Ich will ja nicht, dass irgendeiner UV braucht, um das zu starten.
ich will, dass ich das Binary jemand runterladen kann und einfach ausführen.
CommandLineTool für Aufgabe XY.
Einfach das CommandLineTool runterladen, ausführen und es geht.
Wir können gerne mal einen Stream machen,
wo wir diese ganzen Möglichkeiten für JavaScript und Python mal durchprobieren.
Ob wir mittlerweile...
Wo wir das mal durchprobieren, was es da gibt.
Vielleicht finden wir ja mittlerweile irgendwas, wo das halbwegs machbar ist.
Kann ja sein.
Vielleicht gibt es ja...
Wie gesagt, also mir ist nichts bekannt.
Ich wollte nicht getabbt.
Hallo.
Ich will da wieder zurück.
So, was machen die jetzt?
Ja, genau. Du brauchst weiterhin
UV. Das ist...
Distributing your Python
CLI apps so others can use it.
Email the wheel.
Was? Können die das nicht
packagen als Binary, was ausführbar ist?
Habt ihr gestern
Kern compiled? Ne.
Haben wir nicht.
Müssen wir wahrscheinlich bald, wenn wir das
mit der Netzwerkkarte mal weiter ausprobieren wollen.
Auf dem NAS.
Ja, guck, jetzt musst du hier diese Sachen...
Da brauchst du halt wieder UV und Pip dafür.
Ist halt ein bisschen doof, dass du das dann nicht in ein Self-Contained Binary umwandeln kannst.
Das wäre halt sehr nice.
Markus, können wir mal einen Stream machen zu Monitoring Basics?
Mit was willst du monitoren?
Also wenn du einfach nur Up-Down-Monitoring machen willst, von Ports oder Webseiten oder so, ist Uptime Kuma gar nicht schlecht im Homelab.
Ansonsten ist halt die Frage, willst du eher klassischerweise hostbasiert das Ganze machen?
So läuft der SSH-Dienst, ist SSH offen, ist der Webserver am Laufen und sowas.
Ja, dann müsste man sowas wie Zabbix machen.
Wenn es dir eher geht um Metriken sammeln, wo man auch klassisches Monitoring mitmachen kann,
wenn aber auch ein bisschen komplizierter, dann müsste man Prometheus-mäßig was machen.
Aber Prometheus ist halt in der Regel, wenn du damit klassisches Monitoring machen willst
oder auch wenn du Metriken überwachen willst, eher so ein Do-It-Yourself-System.
Prometheus sammelt Metriken, egal was es ist.
Du musst das alles selbst konfigurieren, alles selbst dafür sorgen, dass es bereitgestellt wird
und dann musst du dir halt überlegen, was du machst mit den Metriken, nachdem du sie hast.
Also Prometheus für sich genommen ist kein Monitoring-System.
Zabbix ist da schon besser, das ist halt ein All-in-One-System.
Wenn aber auch mit einem ekligen Web-Interface.
Ihr wisst, dass ich ein Herz für Nagios habe, aber Nagios in der Form, wie es früher gab, gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Es gibt jetzt ja Nagios X oder sowas, noch nie verwendet.
Und ich würde auch heutzutage kein neues Nagios mehr installieren.
Ich mag Nagios aber, weil es mein erstes Projekt als Azubi war, Nagios zu bauen.
Wie gesagt, in der Firma, wo ich Azubi war, gab es ja keine Ausbildung.
Du konntest entweder drei Jahre chillen und hast nichts gelernt oder du konntest halt ganz normale Sachen machen.
aber ausgebildet hatte ich keiner und mein erstes projekt war halt nagios
nrp agent ich weiß nicht musste den nrp agent für susi kompilieren damals das war
eines der ersten sachen die ich in der ausbildung gemacht habe durchgedreht
bei zum ersten mal irgendwelche compiler make file flex und und hasse nicht gesehen
Damals gab es ja noch kein Chat-GPT.
Ja, das können wir machen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe die blöde Vermutung, da wird nichts bei rauskommen.
Also ich glaube, es gibt keine wirklich gute Lösung dafür.
Aber wir können es mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht gibt es ja mittlerweile irgendwas.
Da müssen wir aber viel googeln und ausprobieren.
Ja.
Also zumindest bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass es nichts geben wird, was an den Workflow von Go rankommt.
Weil was Go angeht, ist Self-Contained Binaries, die überall lauffähig sind, einfach das Beste, was es gibt.
CheckMK ist nicht schlecht.
Wir haben CheckMK auf der Arbeit.
Das CheckMK Webinterface ist halt dermaßen beschissen.
du merkst, dass die 20 Jahre oder so ohne UI-Designer entwickelt haben.
Und das habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht.
Das steht im offiziellen CheckMK-Forum.
Die haben erst seit zwei Jahren oder so einen,
einen, keine Ahnung, wie viele die da haben.
Vielleicht haben die auch zwei.
Die haben erst seit zwei Jahren oder so einen UI-Designer.
Und das siehst du richtig.
CheckMK-Demo.
Mal gucken, ob es sowas gibt.
Erleben Sie CheckMK live.
Erleben.
Ist das jetzt ein Erlebnis oder was?
Monitoring aufmachen zu können. Hier, so.
Check-Am-Car-Demo. Nerv nicht rum.
E-Mail-Adresse.
Keckel.hd
Was? Enter a valid... Moment. Keckel.hd
ist keine valid. Okay.
Example.com
Exit.
OmegaLull.de
Was? Hey, die ist gültig.
Okay, gmx.de
G-Bated.
Wie jetzt?
Ey, woher weiß er, dass das keine gültige E-Mail-Adresse ist?
gmail.com
Noch die Oldschool.
Okay.
Max HD Lull.
Ey!
Was soll das?
Das ist gültig.
Die gibt's.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die gibt
Okay, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat
Wir machen jetzt was anderes
In der Hoffnung, dass es kein Bild dahinter ist, okay?
Hackerman-Zeug
Das ist ein Bild, oder?
Das ist ein Bild
Fuck
Das ist
Das ist so ein Bild
Die Dreckssäge
Okay
E-Mail Adresse
Ähm
Keine Ahnung
Elon Musk
jr. at tesla.com
Ey, was zum...
Ich mag auch
JackMK nicht. Ich wollte euch gerade zeigen, wie kacke
die Webseite ist.
Okay, dann müssen wir uns jetzt Screenshots angucken.
Okay?
Ja, man sieht immer nur die
Dashboards. Man sieht nicht die Settings.
Die Settings ist ja das Eklige.
Ja, so sieht zum Beispiel was aus.
Ja, guck mal.
Guck mal, sowas hier zum Beispiel, ja.
Oder sowas.
Also ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wer dieses...
Wer diese Webseite bei CheckMK designt hat.
Guckt euch das an.
Was ist das für ein Config?
Was ist das für ein Config-Ding?
WTF?
Was zum Teufel hat man hier?
Wer hat das designt?
Das siehst du richtig, dass sie 20 Jahre keinen UI-Designer hatten.
WTF?
Also das Checkmk an sich von den Fähigkeiten, er mag ja durchaus nice sein.
Wir haben das auf der Arbeit auch und das tut seinen Dienst.
Ja, ich bin kein Fan von Checkmk.
Aber dieses Webinterface, das ist so beschissen.
Checkmk UI-Designer.
Mal gucken, ob ich den
den Forum
Post
finde.
I feel like
there was no UX-Team-Member involved
in its deployment.
Ja.
Guck mal, guck mal.
They learned and hired last years ago a UI-Designer.
Also die haben vor drei Jahren oder so
haben die ersten UI...
Einen! Einen fucking UI-Designer!
The UX team was extended by another person.
Das heißt, die haben jetzt zwei.
Die haben zwei UI-Designer.
Krass, oder?
Was ist der Unterschied zu Grafana?
Ja, der große Unterschied ist, dass Grafana nur eine Visualisierungssoftware ist und CheckMK ist eine komplette Monitoringlösung.
Grafana ist ja nur Visualisierung.
Grafana sammelt keine Daten oder irgendwas.
Du kannst CheckMK und Subix beispielsweise als Datenquelle mit Grafana verbinden und dann Grafen in Grafana mit den Daten davon machen.
Das geht.
falls ihr die eigene graphing lösung und so nicht gefällt von zabbix und checkmk
und die grafana grafen sind auch um längen besser als das was zabbix und checkmk da fabriziert
kennt ihr noch diese ganz alten grafen die es früher unter nagios gab ich habe
ich habe vergessen wie diese library hieß diese dinger hier wie hießen denn diese sorten grafen
Die waren mal eine Zeit lang in vielen Monitoring-Tools gang und gäbe.
Da gibt es so diese Dinger hier, diese Graphen.
RRD, genau.
Genau das meine ich.
Diese Dinger hier, das war mal eine Zeit lang voll im Trend.
Und wirklich viel darüber rausgekommen, sind die Graphen in Checkmk auch noch nicht.
und die grafen in Zabbix
sind besser
aber die sind noch nicht auf einem
Niveau von Grafana
Grafana hat für mich das angenehmste
Handling von
so Visualisierungssachen
und Grafana ist mittlerweile auch richtig schön
umfassend was das angeht
also du kannst in Grafana auch wunderbar
die Sachen customizen, die Felder umbenennen
und alles, ja also
Grafana, da gibt es ja auch bestimmt eine Demo
Grafana Demo.
Das ist halt sehr nice.
Playlists.
Explore.
Aber hier siehst du es halt,
in Grafana kannst du halt richtig reinzoomen
und
dir das dann halt genau angucken und so.
das ist schon das ist halt viel viel neuer gibt es hier bei der sports
eigentlich nichts ach hier der sport dem demo alerting demo big worry
welcher welcher hans der hans rosslinger dann hat den graf gemacht okay das ist
natürlich ein bisschen übertrieben da kannst du mit kafana alles machen
brauchst du in der regel meistens machst du sowas hier das ist halt schon als
kannst du jetzt auch groß machen kannst du editieren alles mögliche einstellen
ich also muss man echt sagen kafana ist es für visualisierung für mich das beste
was es gibt hier kannst du kannst queries editieren hat einen guten query editor
ich finde ich finde super also kafana für visualisierung besser aber mit
kafana kannst du halt alleine nichts monitoren
Du hast keine Alerts.
Du hast mittlerweile so ein bisschen Alert, aber dafür ist Grafana nicht gemacht.
Du hast keine gescheiten Alerts.
Du hast keine Daten mit Grafana allein.
Du musst Grafana immer mit mehreren Sachen kombinieren, dass du ordentlich Daten hast.
Du kannst Grafana beispielsweise mit Zabbix als Datenquelle verwenden, Prometheus als Datenquelle verwenden oder am besten beides als Datenquelle verwenden.
Na, gibt's nicht. Gibt es nicht. Das ist ja auch das, was ich seit Jahren sage. Alle Monitoringlösungen sind für sich genommen irgendwie scheiße.
Die haben alle ihre Stärken, ja, aber für sich als Rundumlösung sind alle irgendwie scheiße.
Und falls jetzt irgendwie einer mit PRTG ankommt
Ihr wisst, dass ich dazu nichts sagen kann
Keine Ahnung, ob das gut oder schlecht ist
Das sagt für mich schon mal aus einem ganz anderen Grund
Weil Windows Only
Ich betreibe doch keinen Windows Server
Dafür
Und wahrscheinlich ist es genauso
Crap wie alles andere
Ich kenn's bloß nicht
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen, ja
Aber Windows Only ist ja schon mal
Komplettes Ausschlusskriterium
Das ist eine Marktlücke, ja
Mein Traum ist es ja
Ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt, ich hab ja so ein Herz für Monitoring
sowas zu entwickeln
Somit, sagen wir mit 30 Jahren
Admin-Erfahrung
eine Monitoring-Lösung zu entwickeln, die alles quasi
Ich hätte gerne eine Monitoring-Lösung
die instinktiv
das Richtige macht
für Leute, die sie benutzen, ja
Also eine Monitoring-Lösung, wo du quasi
was anlegst drinnen und dir denkst,
ja, so hätte ich
das auch gemacht.
Was hält dich davon ab? Weißt du, was das für ein Akt ist?
Da ist mein Gehirn
zu klein für, meine Zeit
zu wenig für und
meine Motivation zu gering für.
Auf Dauer.
Das würde ich bestimmt nicht in Rust
machen.
Da dauert es ja noch länger.
Ich würde
Also ich glaube, was ich machen würde
Wenn ich eine Monitoring-Lösung entwickle
Ich würde auf Sachen aufsetzen
Die es schon gibt
Also ich würde keine eigenen
Agents oder sowas programmieren
Ich würde wahrscheinlich auf
Den Prometheus Node-Exportern irgendwie aufsetzen
Vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht
Weil mit denen bin ich auch nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich
Aber für Metric
Oder OpenTelemetry, genau
Aber letztendlich ist es unter der Haube
Auf Linux halt auch nur für System
Sachen, Prometheus Metric
Kram, ja
Nur dass du mit OpenTelemetry noch mehr collecten kannst
Ja, auch irgendwelche Anwendungs-Traces und sowas
Ja, also...
Und um viele Sachen müsste ich mir da auch noch Gedanken machen.
Wie gesagt, ja, ich sehe auch, dass das eine krasse Marktlücke ist.
Ja, SNMP für Linux-Server geht auch.
Es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten. Es gibt ja zig Möglichkeiten, wie du an Daten kommen kannst, ja.
Aber machen wir nochmal eins.
Das ist super kompliziert, das richtig zu machen und ordentlich zu machen und gescheit zu machen.
Das kenne ich nicht. Was ist das? Was ist war zu?
Open Source, XD Open Source, Asiem.
Okay, das ist halt wieder für andere Sachen, ja.
Also als erstes müsste ich mir mal Gedanken machen, auf welcher Basis ich das Ganze entwickle.
Und ich glaube, zwei Sachen, entweder .NET oder Go.
JavaScript fürs Frontend, ja.
Als Datenbank würde ich wahrscheinlich...
Also das Ding ist, ich liebe ja einfache Sachen.
Also Binary runterladen, starten und deine Monitoring Software läuft.
Das ist so für mich der Optimalfall.
ich verstehe aber
dass das
nicht so geil skaliert
was Datenbanken angeht
weil das bedeutet im Endeffekt
SQLite
man kommt mit SQLite sehr weit
es gibt für SQLite
Time Series Extensions und alles mögliche
also man kommt mit SQLite sehr weit
für eine große
für eine riesen Menge an Monitoring
Daten und Metriken ist SQLite
aber wahrscheinlich eher nichts
Das heißt, ich würde wahrscheinlich auf Postgres als einzige Datenbank setzen, weil für Postgres gibt es alles, was du dafür brauchst.
Postgres kann Native Chasen Sachen, ist ein relationales Datenbanksystem, kann ordentliche Volltextsuche, Substring-Suche, hat mit TimescaleDB eine Timeseries-Datenbank.
also kannst du postgres mehr oder weniger alles machen das wahrscheinlich würde ich würde ich
hauptsächlich auf postgres auf postgres setzen und halt vor allem halt für postgres eigenheit
also sachen die es für postgres gibt dies halt für es geliebt an dem fall nicht gibt ja also
wahrscheinlich würde ich auch postgres setzen und als sprache fürs backend.net oder go ein
Ein bisschen tendiere ich zu go.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich ein Ding.
Da träume ich schon lange davon, sowas zu entwickeln.
Aber da brauchst du ein Team aus Leuten, um sowas entwickeln zu können.
Das ist ein Projekt, das braucht bestimmt für eine erste gute Version.
Weil du willst ja auch nichts releasen, was scheiße ist.
Weil sobald du was releast, was scheiße ist,
selbst wenn die zweite Version gut ist, guckt sich das keinem an.
Da brauchst du zwei, drei Jahre dafür, sowas zu entwickeln.
mit einem ordentlichen Team dabei.
Also das ist wirklich,
das ist nix,
was man mal so Hobbyprojektmäßig macht.
Aber ja, ich sehe auch, dass das eine Marktlücke ist.
Es gibt keine gescheite
Monitoring-Software, gibt es einfach nicht.
Und das ist ja auch ein riesengroßes
Feld, ja.
Dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Das ist ein riesengroßes Feld.
Es gibt Anwendungsmetrics,
sowas wie Garbage-Collector-Runs,
Plar-Ramm-Verbrauch-Threads.
Es gibt Anwendungs-Traces, wo du dann irgendwelche Sachen nachvollziehen kannst, wie die Sachen laufen. Traces. Es gibt Logs. Es gibt so klassische System, ich nenne es aber auch Metriken, wie Disk Space. Ist der Port offen? Ja, klassische so Up-Down-Monitoring-Geschichten.
dann willst du solche sachen haben wie welcher user war zuletzt auf dem system eingeloggt falls
dass dieser user war dann alert und so da gehört alerting gescheit dazu visualisierung du brauchst
vor allem ein web interface wurde das alles gescheit konfigurieren kannst dann will ich
natürlich auch dass das ding über config dateien konfiguriert werden kann das ist ein super krass
komplexes
Topic.
Eine richtig gute,
umfassende Monitoring. Das ist wirklich krasses.
Das traue ich mir nicht zu.
Echt?
Ich benutze Tabics bei mir
daheim.
Uptime Kuma
habe ich auch mal eine Weile gehabt. Das hatte mir aber zu wenig
Features.
Ich hab letztens was witziges gesehen auf Reddit
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Reddit
Werbung oder Reddit Ad
Wie heißt das Ding für Windows?
PRTG, ne?
Alternative
Das war so lächerlich
Alter
Das hieß
Ich hab letztens
Ich hab
eine
Reddit-Werbung gesehen,
wo jemand es als Alternative
zu PRTG für, glaube ich,
Zabbix und PRTG angepriesen hat.
Und ich habe mir diese Alternative mal angeguckt
und es war so
schlecht, Alter. Es war so schlecht.
Ich finde das
nicht mehr.
Wie hieß das denn?
Das war eine Werbung, die ich auf Reddit gesehen habe
Und das war richtig schlecht
Ach, wie hieß das?
Das war ein Ad auf jeden Fall
Auf Reddit
Vielleicht kriegen wir, ich mach mal einen Adblocker aus
Vielleicht kriegen wir jetzt ja ein Ad angezeigt hier
Nein, das war es nicht.
Wir refreshen einfach mal die Seite.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das mal angezeigt.
Das ist es auch nicht.
Ich refreshe jetzt einfach so lange, bis ich die Werbung wieder kriege.
Okay, das könnte schwierig sein, das zu finden.
Brauchst du zu Zappi-Extern ja daheim auf einer VM?
Okay, ich finde das nicht mehr
Nein, das war es auch nicht
Das war sowas richtig schlechtes
Das sah aus wie eine Software, die jemand vor 10 Jahren gebaut hat
Das da, das ist es, das ist es
Das ist die Werbung
PRTG Alternative
Da dachte ich mir, ach, interessant
Lasst uns das mal angucken
Passt mal auf, Leute. Ihr seht jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich kenne diese Software nicht, vielleicht ist die auch super, ihr seht jetzt wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das schlechteste Monitoring-System, zumindest vom ersten Eindruck her, was ihr je gesehen habt.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich eine Alternative zu PRTG ist, ja?
Das ist auch nicht besser gewesen.
Genau, guckt euch das Bild an.
WTF?
Was soll das sein?
Das sah Nagios vor 30 Jahren besser aus.
Alter, WTF?
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Ich hab das nur zufällig über die
Ich hab zufällig
Das ist in Perl wahrscheinlich programmiert
Oder sowas noch
Wisst ihr was?
Vielleicht ist das
Leute, das ist bestimmt nicht mal im Browser
Das ist bestimmt eine Desktop-Anwendung
Ne, doch, das ist im Browser
WTF, Mann
WTF?
Customers who trust Power Admin.
Tja, gibt nicht so viel, hä?
Okay, oder, oder, aber
vielleicht steckt es an meinem Darkreader.
Okay, doch, okay.
Wer trusted Power Admin?
Die NASA.
Leute,
Also wie kommt man auf die Idee
Also man muss ja sagen
So eine Produktseite
Ist ja das Aushängeschild von
So einem Produkt
So das heißt der erste Screenshot ist entscheidend
Wie kommt man auf die Idee
Das hier
Als ersten Screenshot rein zu hauen
Was das Produkt verkaufen soll
Das
Alter das sieht aus wie eine selbstgestrickte Seite
die sich in admin einem nachmittag 1996 zusammengebaut hat
und die webseite wie das zuhause in aller
Guck mal hier, das alte
Windows-Internet-Symbol da.
Also mein Beileid
für die Leute, die das benutzen müssen,
vielleicht, und by the way,
nicht, dass ihr mich jetzt verklagt, Power Admin,
vielleicht ist das Produkt auch mega gut.
Aber mein erster Eindruck ist,
es suckt.
Und wir können ja nur den ersten Eindruck bewerten.
Meine Meinung, ja.
Die haben auch keinen UI-Designer.
Aber, Chat, ich habe euch nicht zu viel versprochen, was schlechte Monitoring-Sache angeht, die ich da in Verwerbung gesehen habe, oder?
Also das ist doch wirklich absolut unterirdischer Kram gewesen.
Ah ja.
Sag mal, Chat, blöde Frage.
Bin ich wirklich schon zweieinhalb Stunden online?
Wir haben nichts gemacht.
Was habe ich denn zweieinhalb Stunden gemacht?
Ich habe zweieinhalb Stunden Old Man Yeltsin Cloud gemacht, oder?
Sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, genau.
Aber das war auch nur 20-30 Minuten.
Ja, okay, keine Ahnung.
Dann
habe ich immer wieder alles zu.
Genau, das wollte ich ja noch gucken, was das ist.
Was ist Topcode?
Batteries included framework for building web apps
Aber in Rust
Okay, das heißt ich schreibe dann mein HTML in Rust
Das ist halt die große Preisfrage
Warum?
Es ist ja cool, dass das geht
Aber warum?
Warum nicht einfach HTML und JavaScript?
batteries included ist glaube ich eines der ersten sprüche die python damals hatte batteries
included aber warum also was ist der sinn davon kleinere activity without boilerplate
okay ich halte ich kann so ein bisschen htmx oder so machen
Evaluate and Server for Initial Rendering, also Translation to JavaScript.
Okay, okay, okay, ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Die machen Server-Side-Rendering mit Hydration.
Das ist natürlich cool, dass das eingebaut ist.
Das ist natürlich cool, ne?
Das ist mit, wir machen ein Backend in Go und ein Frontend in HTML und JavaScript nicht so einfach.
Besser gesagt, geht gar nicht richtig.
Das ist natürlich, okay, das verstehe ich.
Das verstehe ich, wo da der Appeal quasi ist davon.
Für alle, die ich jetzt chinesisch geredet habe,
sagt euch Hydration was in Bezug auf Web-Anwendungen?
ansonsten erkläre ich das noch mal kurz weil an sich ist das sind so ein kleiner
trend den es die letzten jahre über gab ich erkläre ich erkläre das einfach
nochmal kurz was was damit gemeint ist also klassischerweise wurden web
anwendungen server site gerendert das bedeutet du bist auf der website
Du hast eine Webseite angefordert von einem Server und du hast komplett quasi...
Ne, kenne ich auch nichts Gutes.
Mein Lieblings-Web-Framework ist immer noch ASP.NET Core.
Früher war das so, wenn du eine Webseite vom Server angefordert hast, dann hast du vom Server fertiges HTML bekommen.
Statisches quasi.
statisches das heißt nicht dass da nicht in line javascript drin sein konnte aber du hast
ein statisches statische webseite bekommen früher bis auf die webseite gegangen statisches html dann
browser hat das gerendert das javascript was da drin war ausgeführt und gut war aber der server
hat statischen text statisches statische seite die er zurückgeliefert ja das war klassisches
server site rendering das lief ja immer so habe ich noch nicht habe ich den letzten aber erst
gesehen dass das jetzt geht also html elemente in canvas rennen kann zwar eine coole sache so
das war so dass oder die klassische sache ja server site rendering so danach und die danach
bedeutet so die letzten sagen wir mal die letzten zehn jahre vielleicht ja ist auch schon ein
bisschen her war der trend ging weg von server site rendering sondern ging ging weg zu kleinzeit
anwendungen also sprich das server beckend hat im endeffekt nur noch apis bereitgestellt mit mit
jason response und es wurde initial eine fette seite ausgeliefert mit ganz viel
javascript drin und das javascript lief dann im browser hat sich von den apn
punkten jason sachen gequere und dann die seite gerendert das war quasi
kleinzeit anwendungen ganz ganz ganz viel jahres gibt der vorteil davon war
du konntest damit halt viel einfacher dynamische webseiten kleinzeit
gerenderte dynamische Webseiten darstellen.
Weil das eben alles auf JavaScript im Browser basierte.
Bei euch auf dem Client.
Vom Server wurden sich einfach nur die rohen Daten im Endeffekt gezogen.
Das war halt super für dynamische Webseiten.
Und der Trend ging ja auch eindeutig zu immer mehr
größeren JavaScript-Anwendungen im Browser.
Sodass heute, wenn du heute Facebook aufmachst,
erst mal 18 MB JavaScript runterlädst.
lädst, damit die Seite überhaupt funktioniert.
Der Vorteil davon war letztendlich,
man könnte sagen, ein bisschen weniger Load auf dem Server, aber vor allem,
wenn die Seite erstmal geladen ist im Browser, ist die Seite sauschnell.
Weil es ist im Endeffekt alles nur noch kleinseitig.
Also kleinseitige Webseiten sind sehr, sehr zackig und sehr dynamisch.
Und das war halt das, was gefragt war, so die letzten
zehn jahre über
gerade noch mal hier die musik wieder an wenn ich es wenn ich es finde
mario kart
mario kart ein
so er hat aber auch nachteile gehabt eines der größten nachteile von
kleinzeit anwendung kleinzeit browser anwendungen war also gibt mehrere
erstens mal die initiale ladezeit du musst es erst mal komplett javascript
komplett große kleinzeit anwendung großen package javascript bmw
javascript runterladen dann musste das javascript vom browser
erstmal ausgeführt werden dann musste das javascript sich von
api endpunkten die daten laden dieses braucht und dann wurde die webseite
gerettet das heißt die webseite bis sie das erste mal hier 30 streams ein stück
bis die webseite das erste mal geladen wurde hat eine weile gedauert bei
Client-Site-Anwendung. Dafür war es danach schnell
und interaktiv.
Und das nächste war,
diese Seiten konnten
ganz schlecht von Suchmaschinen indiziert
werden, weil du hast ja keine
Seite mehr bekommen vom Server, keine fertige
HTML-Seite mehr bekommen.
Du hast minimales HTML und ganz viel
JavaScript bekommen, was an die Seite erst
gerendert hat. Das heißt,
in dem Zustand, wie Google die Webseite
indiziert hat, war darauf überhaupt kein Inhalt zu erkennen.
Das heißt, der Inhalt der Webseite
von diesen rein kleinseitigen JavaScript-Erwerbanwendungen,
die Inhalte konnten nur nicht oder nur sehr schwer von Suchmaschinen indiziert werden.
Was heißt, das Ranking dieser Seiten in Suchmaschinen war halt schlecht.
So, und die letzten paar Jahre kam jetzt ein neuer Trend auf.
Das ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt richtig nenne,
das ist Server-Site-Rendering mit Hydration.
Das bedeutet, du renderst die Seite einmal initial auf dem Server,
lieferst die Seite aus, das heißt, du hast initial schnelle Ladezeiten der Seite.
Die Suchmaschine kann die Seite gut indizieren,
aber dieser initiale State, der auf dem Server erzeugt wird,
also was du brauchst, um die Seite schnell, kleinzeitig und interaktiv zu machen,
Dieser State, den der Server beim initialen Rendern der Seite hat, anstatt den wegzuschmeißen und dann übernimmt das kleinseitig JavaScript, wird das State vom Server, den die Webseite braucht, um kleinseitig zu funktionieren, wird vom Server mitgeschickt.
und dann gibt es so eine Art Bootstrap-JavaScript,
was auf der Seite läuft,
was diesen State quasi dehydrated
und in Client-Site-JavaScript zurück umwandelt.
Das heißt, du hast schnelle initiale Renderzeiten der Seite,
du kannst die Seite gut durchsuchen
und die Seite ist schnell client-seitig gerendert,
funktioniert auch nahtlos client-seitig weiter.
Genau.
so sieht es aus.
Das, was Preserief da auch gerade schreibt.
Das ist,
Server-Syndrom mit Hydration,
das ist so der Trend der letzten paar Jahre.
Den Nachteil davon erkennt man natürlich auch,
das macht es noch ein bisschen komplexer.
So, und dafür ist sowas hier natürlich nice.
Wenn du so ein Web-Framework hast,
das macht das für dich halt.
Deswegen verstehe ich, dass es das gibt.
Okay, macht Sinn, macht Sinn. Ob ich das in Rust machen würde, muss ich nochmal sagen, ich weiß ja nicht. Rust ist für mich eigentlich keine Sprache für sowas, weil die ganze Memory Safety Geschichte ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, bei Web-Anwendungen oder bei Webseiten Backends, wenn du nicht ganz viele Sachen machst, jetzt nicht so krass wichtig.
dass das alles verifizierbar zur Compile-Time-Memory-Save und hast du nicht gesehen ist.
C-Sharp ist auch Memory-Save in dem Sinn.
Das hat quasi Runtime-Bound-Checks für Arrays und Speicher anfordern, freigeben wird eh nicht manuell gemacht.
Also ob du dafür unbedingt Rust brauchst für einen Web-Anwendungs-Backend, weiß ich nicht.
Der Nachteil an Rust ist, das mag zwar alles wunderbar hier so aussehen,
Aber ich kann euch garantieren, dass wenn ihr jetzt eine Aufgabe bekommt, erstellen wir Web-Anwendung XY mit Rust oder mit JavaScript.NET oder JavaScript Rust, wie auch immer, Kombi.
Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich die .NET Anwendung doppelt so schnell fertig haben wie die Rust Anwendung.
Rust ist einfach komplizierter und aufwendiger zu programmieren als sowas wie .NET oder Java oder Go
Das ist einfach so und das müssen auch die krassen Rust-Fans einsehen, dass das so ist
Das ist so, wenn du jemanden hinsetzt, der gut in Rust ist und du setzt einen hin, der gut in Java, .NET oder Go ist
Der hat die gleiche Anwendung in der Regel deutlich schneller erstellt
ohne jetzt vielleicht die Vorteile
von Rust zu haben
die Rust Anwendung, wenn die gescheit
programmiert ist, wird die wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Ecke
noch schneller sein, es ist halt die Frage
ob das eine Anwendung ist, wovon das profitiert
es ist jetzt ja nicht so
als wäre Java.net und Go jetzt irgendwie
langsam für die meisten Anwendungen
aber wenn du sagen wir mal eine Anwendung
hast, die
super, also nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel
nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, ihr wollt
eine
ihr wollt eine Cloud, äh, wie heißt das?
Wie heißt das bei AWS Lambda, glaube ich?
Also ihr wollt eine Anwendung haben, die Serverless, Serverless, jetzt habe ich das Wort,
die Serverless in der Cloud läuft.
Bei Serverless-Anwendungen ist Performance wichtig.
Nicht nur die Runtime-Performance, es ist wichtig,
also die Runtime-Performance ist wichtig,
wie viel RAM verbraucht ist wichtig
und ganz wichtig bei Serverless-Anwendungen, Startup-Time.
Wenn ihr so eine Anwendung habt, dann macht das durchaus Sinn,
sich zu überlegen, wollen wir das vielleicht in Rust oder in C++ oder sowas programmieren,
für den Performance-Aspekt.
Wenn ihr eine Anwendung habt, wo es sehr wichtig ist,
dass die krasse Performance hat und so Memory-Safe wie möglich ist,
dann macht Rust Sinn.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel einen Webbrowser programmiert
oder, sagen wir mal, sicherheitskritische Teile von einem Webbrowser programmiert.
Da macht, es hat übrigens einen Sinn, dass Rust von Mozilla entwickelt wurde.
Da macht Rust Sinn.
Ja?
Bei irgendeinem CLI-Tool, was bei euch,
wenn ihr jetzt ein CLI-Tool programmiert,
was euch morgens in die Zeiterfassung eincheckt
und abends wieder auscheckt per Command-Line,
sind dann die Sache wie super krasse Performance und Memory Safety,
die die Rust bietet zur Compile,
sind die so wichtig?
Würde ich sagen, nee.
Ist eigentlich zu vernachlässigen.
Da mache ich lieber eine Go-Anwendung
und bin doppelt so schnell fertig.
Memory-Safe ist das Ganze auch
und die Performance ist mir egal.
Ob das jetzt in 10 Millisekunden fertig ist
oder in 20 Millisekunden, juckt mich in dem Fall nicht.
Also man muss wirklich auch immer gucken,
für was entwickelt man das?
Also sprich, was sind dann meine Anforderungen dahinter?
Einfach zu sagen, ich nehme immer Rust.
Kann man machen,
wenn man Rust-Fan ist und es ein Hobbyprojekt
ist und beliebig viel Zeit hat,
wenn es darum geht, in einem Team
zusammenzuarbeiten, eine größere Anwendung
zu erstellen, wo es um
bestimmte Funktionen geht und
dass es auch nicht fünf Jahre dauert,
ist vielleicht Rust nicht zwangsläufig das
Beste.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn es eine Anwendung ist,
wo das wichtig ist, die Vorteile von Rust,
dann gib ihm Rust.
Also wie gesagt,
Ich glaube nicht, dass Rust hier meine Anwendung oder meine Sprache und das hier das Framework meiner Wahl wäre, wenn ich eine Web-Anwendung erstellen möchte.
Ah ja.
Ich weiß, dass ich damit zu rational umgehe. Viele Rust-Anwendungen werden einfach erstellt, weil sie written in Rust sind.
Anderweitig kann ich mir das auch nicht erklären,
warum es so viele Rewrites von perfectly feinen Tools in Rust gibt.
Also, ich sag's ja, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt,
ich find es cool, dass es solche Projekte gibt.
Also ich find es cool, dass jemand sagt, ey, guck mal,
wir rewriten die Linux Core Utils, also Core Utils,
Das ist sowas wie ls, sed, grep, find, awk und so Gedöns.
Wobei ich gar nicht weiß, ist awk Core Utils?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, also diese Standard Linux Kommandozeilen-Tools,
die standardmäßig auf jedem Linux-System zur Verfügung stehen,
die werden hier in Rust rewritet.
Mal gucken, ob man hier die ganzen Programme irgendwo auch sieht.
Vielleicht, wenn man Glück hat.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja, wo sieht man den ganzen Kram hier überhaupt?
Tja, keine Ahnung.
Wo sieht man denn die ganzen Programme?
Ah, hier, hier sieht man es.
Guck.
Ja, also Base64-Encoding,
Basename, CAT,
CHON, CHMOD,
CHROOT, CHECKSUM,
CUTDATE, DD, DF.
Okay.
Es ist überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches dagegen,
diese Dinger in Rust zu rewriten.
da lernt man bestimmt sehr viel dabei
und vielleicht ist das
in Zukunft auch was, wo man sagen kann
vielleicht löst das mal ab
ok
das ist ok
dass Canonical bzw. Ubuntu
jetzt auf die Idee kommt
diese Tools als Standard-Tools
einzuführen, halte ich für eine blöde Idee
weil die Dinger noch nicht
Feature-Complete sind und immer noch Kompatibilitätsprobleme
haben
Und ich habe letztens erst wieder News gelesen, dass das aktuelle Ubuntu Daily Build, was es gibt, von dem Ubuntu, wo das drin ist, mal wieder kaputt war, weil es irgendeine Inkompatibilität zwischen einem Rust Rewrite der Core Utils und den echten Core Utils gibt.
Meine persönliche Meinung ist, diesen Rewrite braucht es eigentlich nicht.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, diese Core-Utils, das sind Client-Side-Tools,
bis auf ganz spezielle Sachen, ja?
Also so Sachen wie Sudo zum Beispiel.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das hier dabei ist überhaupt.
Ja? Sudo und sowas.
Es gibt ein paar Core-Utils, wo ich sagen würde,
ja, okay, da macht es vielleicht Sinn, aber für 99% der Core-Utils,
das sind irgendwelche Client-Side-Anwendungen,
die seit 50 Jahren oder so bestehen, natürlich weiterentwickelt werden, immer noch, sporadisch,
die aber vor allem krass getestet sind.
Also diese Standardsachen wie LS, HAT, DD und sowas.
Es gibt kaum Software, die so gut getestet ist wie diese.
das wird täglich millionen von millionen verwendet täglich und der kram funzt halt einfach also ich
verstehe nicht warum es diesen rewrite gebraucht hat er war manchen sachen wie sudo und so kann
ich schon nachvollziehen ja besuche ist ein spezieller fall aber bei base 64 alter warum
brauche ich das Base64
Command in Rust re-implemented?
Warum?
Wozu?
Also wer hat sich jemals gedacht,
Base64, oh fuck
Alter, wer Base64
jetzt mal in Rust programmiert, der hätte ich viel weniger
Probleme.
Ja.
Oh, wäre das jetzt in Rust gewesen, dann in Placingly Fast und überhaupt.
Und natürlich, streng genommen, ja, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass in Base64 eine Sicherheitslücke drin ist.
Und wenn ich hier einen speziellen manipulierten String reinhau, dann führt Base64 den Upload von meinen SSH-Keys durch.
Das wäre theoretisch denkbar
Das ist übrigens auch bei Rust nicht ausgeschlossen
Weil gegen Logikfehler macht Rust nichts
Gegen irgendwelche Overflows und so
Hättest du das Problem bei Rust dann nicht
Also theoretisch ist das möglich
Aber es ist enorm unwahrscheinlich
Dass so ein Fehler unerdeckt in Base64 steckt
Im schlimmsten Fall, was passiert, ist Base64
crasht, wenn du da irgendeinen Input reinhaust,
mit dem es nicht klarkommt.
Das ist sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Naja.
Also das zu diesen ganzen
Rust-Rewrites.
Und wie sind wir da drauf gekommen?
Achso, wegen dem Web-Framework
in Rust.
Also cool, dass es solche Sachen gibt.
Was ich besonders cool finde, ist, dass das ein Framework von den Tokio Leuten ist.
Die haben ja einen guten Track Record.
Also was die machen, das wird in der Regel halt auch über eine lange Zeit supportet und funktioniert.
Das ist halt was, was man mal ausprobieren könnte.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, mein Mittel der Wahl für, ich muss mal eine Web-Anwendung erstellen, wird es nicht werden.
Also für mich ist die beste Kombination, wenn ich eine Anwendung haben möchte, die
einfach zu verteilen ist und ein Webinterface hat, wäre entweder .NET mit AOT mit ein paar
Einschränkungen oder aber Go.
Und dann würde ich das ganz simpel machen.
ein Go-Backend, ein JavaScript-Frontend,
dann würde ich das JavaScript embedden in mein Go-Binary
und das als self-contained Go-Binary ausliefern.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann startet die Go-Anwendung, du gehst auf die Webseite drauf
und kriegst das Webinterface ausgeliefert.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
JavaScript, quasi die Web-Anwendung in einem Go-Binary zu embedden,
ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Und der Go-Webserver liefert die dann einfach aus.
Du meinst sowas wie Ruby und Rails?
Das ist das Batteries-Included-Web-Framework, was mir so einfällt.
Da ist ja alles dabei.
ASP.NET Core kommt auch ran vielleicht.
ja. Aber für Rust und Go
ist mir da auch, ich habe mich
auch nicht wirklich großartig mit beschäftigt, aber ist mir
zumindest nichts bekannt.
Bei Go ist ja der Trend dahin,
gar keine Frameworks zu verwenden,
sondern alles mit der Standard-Library zu machen.
Was ich auch
ein bisschen fragwürdig finde.
Man muss sich nicht,
um sich zwei Zeilen zu sparen,
ja, einen 10.000 Zeilen
Framework reinhauen, das
verstehe ich schon. Aber so
Sobald es ausartet und eklig wird, kann man sich durchaus ein Framework holen oder eine Library holen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man viel Daten filtern muss und umsortieren muss und sowas, da ist die Go-Standard-Library einfach kacke.
Weil ihr wisst, was die Go-Standard-Library sagt zum Thema Filter in ein Array.
Wisst ihr, was die Go-Standard-Library sagt?
Also wenn man mal sowas von JavaScript ausgeht, dann würdest du sowas hier machen.
Filter, äh, keine Ahnung,
X größer 2.
So, das würdest du in JavaScript
machen. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das
richtig ist. Ich, warte mal, ich führe das mal in JavaScript aus.
Note. Habe ich nicht laufen?
Habe ich Bann laufen? Bann, ne, äh.
Kann man, kann man in Bann
rappeln? So, bam.
Syntaxerror, okay.
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Ah, es ist, Moment, es ist so, es ist so, oder?
Okay, also.
in javascript ist es halt total einfach zu sagen ich habe einen array mit 1 2 3 4 5 ich finde das
array nach elementen die größer als zwei sind also krieg ich den urlaub wo 345 drin ist wenn
ich sage gleich zwei kommt natürlich nur zwei und wenn ich sagen kleiner zwei kommt nur eins
wenn ich nach kleiner gleich zwei 1 und 2 also das ist easy super easy das geht ihnen so gut
wie allen programmier sprachen wisst ihr was golda wisst ihr die antwort von go hierzu die
die Go sagt, dass man sowas machen soll.
Wir lassen uns das jetzt mal
in ChatGPT, weil
vielleicht hat ChatGPT eine Refinephät-Idee, die ich nicht
habe.
In Go.
Genau. So sieht's aus.
Das ist das Go-Gegenstück
dazu. Das muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Ein Array filtern.
Es gibt keine Antwort
in der Go-Standard-Library, ein Array zu
filtern.
du musst
ein leeres Ziel-Array anlegen,
du musst loopen
über das
Standardmäßige, über das Array,
dann machst du ein If da drinnen und dann
appendest du das an das Ziel-Array.
Ich weiß, das ist die Philosophie von Go.
Die Philosophie von Go ist ja,
du sollst das alles möglichst explizit
machen. Ich bin
aber der Meinung, man kann es auch
übertreiben.
Und es gibt ein paar Libraries für Go, die solche so Link-mäßige wie in C-Sharp Funktionen anbieten.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel, Mo heißt das glaube ich für Go.
Mo oder so.
Filter oder Mu oder so.
Oder Mu oder so irgendwie heißt das.
Keine Ahnung.
Lo.
Oh, ich weiß es nicht.
Wie das?
Lo.
Ah ja, der Typ, der hat mehr Libraries, die so komische Namen haben.
Ja, da gibt es sowas.
Und ganz ehrlich, so eine Library zu verwenden, wenn man öfters...
Wenn man hier öfters so sortieren muss oder Unix-Strings von einem Array rausfinden muss,
finde ich das nicht verkehrt, dafür eine Library zu verwenden, ja?
Wenn man das öfters macht. Man muss sich ja nicht mehr quälen.
Dafür haben wir jetzt komische Iterator-Syntax in Go.
Oh, ist das was Neues? Die kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel?
So, wollen wir uns übrigens nochmal schocken?
And how to do in C++?
Give me more than, give me five examples.
Das muss man machen bei C++, weil du kannst in C++ alles dreimal machen.
So, in C++ kannst du Standardfilter verwenden.
das macht aber also c++ ist die einzige sprache wenn man dort konstrukte in der
standard library verwendet die bestimmte sachen vereinfachen sollen macht es das komplizierter
Ne, ich meine die Iterator Syntax in Go
Ob du dafür ein Beispiel
Go Iterator Syntax, die kenne ich noch nicht
Ist das neu?
Range over Iterators
Ja, aber damit kann ich es doch immer noch nicht
filtern. Ich muss doch nach wie vor ganz normal filtern.
Das ist mit Yield
wie in C Sharp, wo du dann quasi
Sequenzen erzeugen kannst.
Aber das hilft dir ja nicht, das irgendwie
besser zu filtern, einfacher zu filtern.
Okay, pass mal auf C++.
Okay, jetzt macht... Okay, das hat mich nicht richtig
verstanden, aber okay, dann...
Oh, ich hab mich
hier verschrieben. Das hat recht.
Okay, C++, guck hier.
Du kannst natürlich auch das in C++
genauso machen. Reusable Filter
Function. Komplett Blödsinn. Standard Library
Algorithm. Ja.
Ja. Guck mal. Das ist halt
ey. C++. Seriously.
C++ ist so
eine dermaßen dämliche
Sprache.
Guck dir mal hier. Also. Wir haben die
Möglichkeit in C++
es von Hand zu machen.
Ja. Also. Ich leg
ich hab mein Quellvektor
ich hab nen Zielvektor
und ich mache das wie in Go.
Ich mache eine Schleife
über jedes Element.
Das hat übrigens C++ auch noch nicht so lang, diese Syntax.
Ich mache eine Schleife über jedes Element.
Dann mache ich ein if da drin und gucke.
Elemente, kleiner gleich 2
und dann pushe ich es in den Zielvektor.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht
elegant, aber das ist
straightforward lesbar.
Und jetzt kommt die Sache,
was C++ anbietet, um es
einfacher zu machen, in Anführungsstrichen.
Das ist die einfachere Variante.
Wie gesagt, C++ ist die einzige Sprache,
wo, wenn man Abstraktionen verwendet,
der Code unlesbarer wird.
Guck mal, das hier ist komplett fein.
Du verstehst alles.
Das hier ist sogar noch länger.
Das ist sogar noch länger als das hier.
Und soll einfacher sein?
Das ist so dumm.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Du brauchst nach wie vor...
Also, du brauchst nach wie vor dein Quellenziel-Array, dann brauchst du Standard-Copy-If, du musst dieses hässliche Beginn-und-End-Iterator-Geschiss setzen.
Warum das ein Ding ist, verstehe ich bis heute nicht.
Dann musst du aus irgendwelchen Gründen Standard-Back-Inserter benutzen.
Ist der AF-Block? Ne, wer ist das? Wir haben noch jemand im Chat, der mimt immer, wenn man Standard-Back-Inserter sagt rum.
Er ist aber gerade nicht da anscheinend, ja.
Dann musst du aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Standard Back-Inserter nehmen,
dass die Results von hinten anhängt,
anstatt nach vorne.
Und dann musst du diese hässliche
C++ Lambda Syntax verwenden, um zu filtern.
Das ist so dämlich.
Meine Frage, meine Frage,
das ist eine Frage,
die ich auch gerne mal das C++ Gremium fragen würde.
Wobei ich es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht gerne machen würde,
weil die Antwort ist wahrscheinlich wieder richtig abartig, ja.
Also Syntax, kann man das irgendwie so machen?
Ach, keine Ahnung, wie man das in...
Also, warum kann ich nicht?
Warum gibt es in C++ nicht sowas hier?
Also, ich habe einen Vektor mit Zahlen drin.
Übrigens, diese Art und Weise, den Vektor zu initialisieren,
ist auch so ein Ding für sich.
Es gibt, glaube ich, 17 verschiedene...
Das ist kein Witz, Leute, das ist kein Witz.
Ich glaube, es gibt 17 verschiedene Varianten in C++, eine Variable zu initialisieren.
Das ist kein Spaß.
Ich kann euch das...
Warte mal.
Hier, Chat.
Always to initialize a Variable in C++.
Okay.
Mal gucken, ob das die...
Okay, immerhin kann ChatGPT mein dummes Zeug.
Guck mal.
Default Initialization, Copy Initialization, Direct Initialization, Uniform Initialization, Value Initialization, Reference Initialization, Ponder Initialization, Auto Initialization, Constructor Initialization, Dynamic Initialization, Array Initialization, STL Container.
What the fuck C++? Was ist mit euch kaputt im Hirn in diesem Gremium, Alter?
So, zumindest ich habe eine Frage. Also guck mal.
Warum?
Warum ist man nicht hergegangen und sagt,
man kann sowas hier machen?
Ich weiß, ich weiß, komplett abgedrehte Idee, ja, für C++.
Aber warum kann man nicht einfach sowas machen?
Nams?
Pilter?
Ja?
Und wir behalten meinetwegen auch diese eklige C++-Syntax.
Int x.
Meinetwegen, dass man auch noch int.
Ja, warum kann man nicht einfach Auto x schreiben?
Geht wahrscheinlich auch.
Und warum kann ich nicht dann einfach sagen,
Return x kleiner gleich 2.
Warum geht das nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Warum brauche ich so einen Scheiß wie Standard Copy-If?
Hast du die C++-Doku auf YouTube angeschaut?
Die Doku nicht, aber ich habe das ultimative C++-Frame-Video
sehr zu meiner Genugtuung auf YouTube angeschaut.
Warum? Warum baut man nicht einfach sowas ein?
Ja
Ich kann den Gedankengang des C++ Gremiums
Irgendwie verstehen
Die sagen, ja wir wollen
Generische Methoden in der Standard Library haben
Und wir wollen die nicht jetzt explizit
Auf Vector definieren
Aber warum?
Wen fucking juckt's?
Vector ist eines der meist benutzten Typen
in C++?
Warum nicht einfach auf Vektor eine Filter-Methode?
Und noch besser, warum
returnt diese Filter-Methode
nicht einfach einen neuen Vektor,
wo die Elemente drin sind?
Warum muss ich noch explizit sagen,
ich will es in diesen Vektor sortieren, Standard
Back-Inserter. What the fuck?
Ja, Filtersyntax, Standard
View, Filter, können wir uns auch mal
ein Beispiel angucken. Das ist jetzt relativ
neu.
Das ist jetzt relativ neu, by the way, obviously.
Also, Chat, Cringe
wirklich also wer das nicht versteht was hier steht der sollte eigentlich sofort
an installen also das ist so ob wir uns c++ was hier steht es gibt eigentlich
keine möglichkeit das nicht zu verstehen
example
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Da muss ich Chat geben.
Standard View
Filter
Standard View Filter
C++
Filtering Array
Vector
Okay, immerhin.
Immerhin gibt es jetzt mittlerweile so eine...
Hey, hey.
Das ist echt in Ordnung, wenn das funktioniert.
Wenn das geht, ist das okay.
Also das ist was.
Das lasse ich mir sogar gefallen.
Das lasse ich mir...
Das geht noch.
Ich meine, das ist immer noch ein bisschen umständlich, ja.
Aber das geht noch.
Ja, warum das wieder überladen wurde mit so einem extra Syntax-Ding, keine Ahnung, verstehe ich nicht.
Aber das ist irgendwie noch in Ordnung.
Warum es hier diesen Pipe Operator braucht und so, whatever.
Aber C++ hat eh jedes Sonderzeichen auf der Tastatur.
Zweck entfremdet für irgendwas schon.
wozu es tausend Alternativen gibt.
Na, manchmal musst du...
Du meinst Alternativen zu C++?
Naja, manchmal musst du C++ verwenden.
Ja, also das ist eine Sache.
Das finde ich,
das geht ja noch klar mittlerweile.
Das ist ja schon noch okay.
Irgendwo. Also in C++-Sphären,
in C++-Logik
ist das ja noch okay.
Ja, problematisch, seit wann gibt es das? C++20? Das heißt, die meisten Leute, die C++ verwenden, können es wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden. Moment, Moment, Standard Views. Lass uns mal kurz gucken. Compiler Support. Compiler Support. Standard View Filter.
Gibt es da irgendwie sowas?
Oh, da muss ich nach Standard View gucken
Okay
Standard View
View
What the fuck, Alter
Ich check's, ne
Filter
Filter View Extensions.
Das ist er, oder?
Ist es das?
Man erkennt bei C bloß nicht mal
anhand der Benamung, was was ist.
Okay, also anscheinend kann das
nur C... Gucken wir mal,
was das...
Ja, das ist das.
Das ist das. Okay.
Es kann aktuell sogar nur
GCC.
Kein anderer Compiler kann es außer GCC
Geil
C++
Aber Moment, das ist 26
Ist das erst seit 26?
Standard View Filter
Oder muss ich Standard Ranges View Filter
What the fuck, was brauche ich denn hier überhaupt
Seit C++ 20
Gibt es das
Ey, keine Ahnung
Kein Schimmer, es ist C++
Okay
Welche Compiler
Unterstützen das?
Mal gucken, ob
Guck auch im Internet nach
Gucken, ob ChatGPT da eine Antwort drauf hat
Ranges, Ranges muss ich suchen
Ranges
Standard Ranges, Ranges Cache
SVue Input, Ranges
Ja, welches denn?
Ranges?
Ja, welches davon denn?
Ranges Find?
Ranges Contain?
Ranges
Ey
Boah, Mann, C++, Alter
Diese
Ist so ein Abfuck, diese Sprache, Mann
Äh, das glaube ich erst.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist wirklich, also C++ ist wirklich, für jedes gute Feature führen die drei Beschissene ein.
Das hier würde ich in C++-Maßstäben als gutes Feature sogar noch werten.
Warum man es wieder so komisch gemacht hat, mit einem extra Zeichen und sowas.
Also, ne?
Warum man nicht einfach sagen kann
Vektor, Filter und gut ist
Keine Ahnung
Warum man es so kompliziert macht
Aber das würde ich ja noch als gutes Feature im C++ Universum ansehen
Jemand bei meinen Kunden hat mir letztens glücklich erzählt
Dass er jetzt endlich C++14 Featuret
Ja, zwölf Jahre danach
Der weiß noch nicht, was auf ihn zukommt, das stimmt
C++14 ist ja gerade bei Autopointer
was mittlerweile wieder abgeschafft wurde.
Hat er schon die wunderschöne
Chrono-API mit C++14?
Letztens auf Reddit hat einer geschrieben,
dass die Chrono-API eines der
besten Daytime-Implementierungen ist
für an allen Programmiersprachen, die es gibt.
Ich zweifle
wirklich an der geistigen Gesundheit von
vielen Leuten mittlerweile.
Wer zum Teufel denkt,
dass die Chrono-API in C++
eines der besten Daytime-API-Implementierungen
ist. Wollen die mich komplett
verarschen?
Ja, machen wir mal.
Chrono Convert
to Milliseconds.
Chrono System
Time in Milliseconds.
Obviously.
Na klar.
Oh, das ist so gut lesbar,
Leute. Oh, das ist, das ist eindeutig,
Leute, das ist die beste Date-Time-RP,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Das kann ich,
das geht nicht besser.
Das ist noch nie, genau,
Chat, noch nie sowas Schönes
gesehen. Standard
Chrono-Duration-Cast, Standard
Chrono-Milliseconds-Duration-Count.
Kann man inzwischen einen String splitten?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Hat Standard
String mittlerweile einen Split?
Anscheinend nicht.
Oder doch?
Da muss es doch mittlerweile was ordentliches geben.
Das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Das ist wirklich...
Es gibt wirklich keine Standard-Library-Variante in C++, um ein String zu splitten.
Das ist komplett geisteskrank.
Geisteskrank, du hast recht.
Patrick, du hast recht. Das ist wirklich komplett geisteskrank.
Das ist komplett geisteskrank, Alter.
Easy way, easy way, split string in C++.
Das gibt wirklich nichts.
Es gibt nichts?
Ernsthaft?
Wie beschissen möchte eine Sprache sein?
String Split?
Ach, das braucht man nicht.
Es kann sich ja jeder ein eigenes Template copy-pasten von GitHub.
Also die Sprache ist wirklich geisteskrank.
Es ist einfach so.
Unfassbar.
Ich weiß, die C++-Fans...
Wisst ihr, ich weiß sogar die Antwort von C++-Fans da drauf,
warum Standardsplit nicht geht.
Die Antwort von C++-Fans ist,
weil Standards String ja kein Encoding kennt,
kann es auch nicht erkennen, was ein Leerzeichen ist.
Wetten? Wetten? Ich wette mit euch.
Das ist die Antwort.
Da sehen wir aber schon mehrere Probleme.
Also erstens,
warum kennt das kein Encoding?
Warum sagen die nicht einfach,
okay, wir machen Standard String UTF-8.
dass sie Standard-String nicht ändern wollen
im Default-Behaviour kann ich verstehen
die machen einfach U8-String
und dann gehen die halt
einfach davon aus, alle Strings
damit sind UTF-8, was eh die meisten
Dinger sind, weil UTF-8
included ASCII
das heißt mit UTF-8
hast du wahrscheinlich
95% der Encodings abgedeckt
und das könnte man durchaus
Default-mäßig in der Standard-Library
Rust macht das by the way so
Ja, C-Sharp nicht, aber selbst C-Sharp hat mittlerweile UTF-8 Strings.
C-Sharp ist UTF-16, weil C-Sharp älter ist, als diese ganzen Standards gab, aber sogar C-Sharp hat mittlerweile UTF-8 Strings.
Und das Ding ist halt, wie man kann nicht erkennen, was ein Leerzeichen ist.
Wenn man sich darauf einigen würde, es wäre UTF-8, ist es wahrscheinlich relativ einfach,
einfach sich auf eine
Sensible
Default zu einigen, welche Zeichen
als Leerzeichen und Newlines gelten.
Oder aber man könnte sogar
sagen, Default ist halt ASCII
Encoding und da ist es
nur relativ obvious, welche Zeichen
in String gesplittet werden
kann. Also das ist alles
kein Problem. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum
die da so eine Wissenschaft draus machen.
Aber ich meine, wer braucht schon
String Split?
so String Operations kommen ja, hat ja der Chat
auch geschrieben, String Operations
sind ja auch so selten, wie die vorkommen
gibt's ja kaum
String Operations
braucht man nicht, aber immerhin
C++ hat
mittlerweile toUpperCase
immerhin, ja
gibt das mittlerweile
also
Easily.
Das mittlerweile gibt es.
So, so, so.
Transformt ihr in C++ einen String in Uppercase.
Ich bilde mir eigentlich ein.
Ich dachte C++ Standard String hat mittlerweile eine To Upper oder To Lower Methode.
Oder nicht?
Fragezeichen.
Stern hat String.
Hat's nicht?
Standard View Split gibt es wohl.
Aha.
Standard Range is transformed.
Das habe ich auch gerade gefunden.
Das sieht dann so aus.
Alter, was eine geisteskranke Sprache, oder?
WTF?
Was eine geisteskranke Sprache.
Input Text Begin and Begin.
To Upper.
Oh Mann
Egal, genug C++
Ich
Ich riech mich schnell doof
Okay, okay, das reicht jetzt
Bammel
Programming language for agents, okay
Leute, ich muss
Ich muss mich mal kurz
Kurz, äh, ausruhen
Und
Und ein bisschen Tee trinken
Das war zu viel C++ Rage.
Ich hab meine Garmin-Uhr leider nicht an.
keine ahnung was ich gerade für ein puls hat aber bestimmt 120 oder so
durch die aufregung
ich schenke jetzt mal langsam ein tee noch mal auswarten
So, ich glaube...
Ich glaube, jetzt geht es wieder.
Meine Güte.
Ich muss gucken.
Ihr habt recht, Chat. Ich muss gucken, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Was macht die Mikrowelle?
Nichts?
Oder doch?
Ich frage mal kurz, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Zehn Minuten gibt's Essen.
Die geht nicht von allein an.
Ich hab so eine smarte Steckdose an der Mikrowelle.
Und da erkenne ich, wenn die Mikrowelle an ist, anhand der...
Also das ist eine smarte Steckdose, die den Stromverbrauch messen kann.
Und wenn Mittagessen unten zubereitet wird in der Küche,
dann erkenne ich das.
Und dementsprechend weiß ich, es gibt bald Essen.
So.
Hast du schon mal
Meta over Threat probiert? Ne.
Meine Mutter
bereitet das zu.
Seit den letzten
13 Jahren
kriege ich Mitterressen von meiner Mutter wieder gemacht.
Das ist exzellent.
Ich könnte mir nichts Angenehmeres vorstellen.
Ja, wir wohnen im gleichen Haus wieder.
Meine Mutter hat 2013 das Haus vom Opa geerbt.
Und da war halt die Frage, verkaufen oder einziehen?
Die ist ja nicht verheiratet
Die hat zwar
Hat zwar nen Freund, aber
Der ist nur zweimal die Woche oder so da, also
War halt die Möglichkeit
Die verkauft das
Alleine hier wohnen war ihr nix
Was ich auch verstehen kann, ja
Oder sie hätte ihren Kerl geheiratet
Und wären die hier zusammen eingezogen, das wollten sie aber
Beide nicht, was ich auch verstehen kann
Ähm
Oder wir ziehen zusammen ein, da war ich sofort
Dabei, ganz ehrlich, es gibt nix
Besseres wie, du musst dich nicht
um Wäsche kümmern, du musst dich nicht um Essen kümmern
und du musst dich nicht um so
Basics Sachen wie Staubsaugen kümmern.
Wobei ich Staubsaugen tatsächlich öfters selbst
mache hier oben.
Weil die ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter
und das ist immer so schultermäßig so anstrengend,
meinen Teppich zu saugen hier oben.
Aber es gibt nichts besseres.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ja, und ich weiß, viele Leute sagen, oh, cringe
mit fast 42.
Ganz ehrlich,
juckt mich nicht.
Beste.
Und man spart sau viel Geld.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei.
Beste.
Allemal besser als in der Kackwohnung vorher.
Vorher habe ich ja zur Miete gewohnt.
In so einer mittlerweile bisschen Assi-Ecke in Hanau.
War halt billig.
Und mittlerweile, ich laufe da öfters mal vorbei,
mittlerweile ist da noch mehr Assi.
Also, das hat schon angefangen, als ich da noch bis 2013 in der Wohnung gewohnt habe.
Aber mittlerweile ist da noch mehr Assi.
Habt ihr da auch geteiltes Internet?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Warum?
Nee, nee.
Technik im ganzen Haus mache ich.
Deswegen funzt das auch alles.
Nee, nee, WLAN.
Also, den Internetzugang benutzen wir zusammen.
WLAN hier ist geshared und alles.
Ja, nee, das nicht.
Warum auch?
Übrigens, es gibt in Hanau so eine richtig geile Asie-Ecke.
Die muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Muss mal kurz...
Da wollte ich eigentlich nicht hin.
Muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das finde.
Hanauer Hauptbahnhof.
Hier hinter irgendwo.
Hier irgendwo hinter.
Hier gibt es ein Haus.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das das ist.
Es gibt hier ein Haus.
Da ist ein Gitter.
Ein Gitter am Erdgeschoss.
Damit die Leute nicht einbrechen.
Der hat sich quasi ein eigenes Gefängnis am Erdgeschoss gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo das ist.
Irgendwo hier hinten ist das.
Wollte ich euch mal zeigen.
Vielleicht hier?
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwo hier hinten.
Gibt es...
Hier?
Der hat sich selbst eingezäunt,
dass keiner einbricht bei ihm.
Warte mal.
Vielleicht doch dieses Haus hier unten?
Ist hier eingezäunt irgendwo?
Nee, ne?
Keine Ahnung.
Dann weiß ich es nicht.
Aber gab es hier hinten irgendwo?
Also in ganz einer schlimmen Ecke habe ich nicht gewohnt.
Ah ja.
Ja, excellent.
Keine Ahnung.
Das war immer lustig, dran vorbeizulaufen,
wo ich mir denke, Alter, was ist das für eine Scheißgegend sein muss,
wenn du schon einzäunen musst, dass dir keiner einbricht.
Ich war letztens in Offenbach, da ist komplett der Absturz.
Hey, ich hab gelesen, das stimmt gar nicht.
Angeblich geht's in Offenbach voll bergauf
im Vergleich zu vielen anderen hessischen Städten.
Letztens ist ein Artikel erst drüber gelesen.
Offenbach soll richtig gut sein
in den richtigen Ecken
Hörensagen
Ich selber hab nie in Offenbach gewohnt
Ja, im Lampau ist auch
Asi, ja
Im Lampau hab ich auch mal gewohnt
Aber schon lange nicht mehr, glücklicherweise
Im Lambo, ja genau
Hey, mal eine andere Frage
Was gerade ist, ne
Ich hab das ja nicht so verfolgt, aber
Habt ihr mal eine Ahnung, was bei ApoRed
Eigentlich gerade rausgekommen ist
Das letzte, was ich gehört habe
Wer Ahnung davon hat, könnt mich ja mal schnell auf den aktuellen Stand bringen.
Das letzte, was ich gehört habe, ist, dass es quasi sexuelle Belästigungsvorwürfe gegenüber ApoRed gegeben hat.
Dass er wohl irgendwie eine Minderjährige oder eine Jugendliche sexuell belästigt haben soll.
Angeblich in seinem Haus in... keine Ahnung, wo er wohnt.
und da war der Aufschrei dann riesengroß
und Gott um die Welt und halb YouTube
Deutschland hat Videos
gemacht, aber ihr wisst ja, ich kann mir YouTube Deutschland
nicht angucken, ich krieg da Anfälle
und da hab ich mich gerade eben so gefragt
was macht eigentlich
der echte Maincharakter gerade
ist das immer noch
akut oder hat sich das mittlerweile
entkräftet oder hat sich das
mittlerweile bewahrheitet
hat da irgendjemand einen Überblick
So, ein Satz.
Okay, wisst ihr auch nicht, was ich gut finde, dass ihr das nicht wisst.
Weil ich glaube, das ist...
Nix, was man im Kopf behalten will.
Was der Kerl macht.
Ah, Sano, danke schön für den Sub.
Es bestätigt sich immer mehr, dass es kein Champion ist.
Ja.
Ey, ich verfolge das auch nicht so.
Hat mich einfach nur interessiert, was der jetzt so treibt.
Der echte Main-Character.
Das ist so dämlich, Alter.
Ist das eigentlich immer noch angesagt, ja?
Dass er der einzige echte Main-Character ist.
Nun ja.
So, Leute.
Borsa ist fertig runtergeladen.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Es gibt dort keine Nudeln mit Lachs und auch keine Spaghetti Bolognese.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Haben wir es wirklich ernsthaft geschafft,
dreieinhalb Stunden
sinnloses Zeug zu schwätzen,
ohne dass wir uns irgendwie
zwischendurch da YouTube-mäßig oder sonst
irgendwas angeguckt haben?
Okay.
dreieinhalb Stunden Old Man Yeltsin Cloud.
Top.
Gibt es später Streams? Oh, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich muss später noch 46 Minuten rennen.
Ganz bestimmt.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema waren,
Monitoring Software in C++-Programmieren
geht ja gar nicht,
weil C++ keine gescheite
HTTP-Server und generell Netzwerk-Implementation
in Socket-Implementation und Gedöns in der Standard-Library hat.
Hast du nicht.
Du musst quasi das vom Betriebssystem,
die C-APIs vom Betriebssystem nehmen
und da gibt es halt auch keinen Web-Server.
Das heißt, du brauchst eine externe Web-Server-Library.
Kannst schon mal vergessen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie eine Standard-Library
von einer verbreiteten Programmiersprache,
die auch schon General Purpose sein will,
im Jahr 2026
nicht zumindest einen Mini-Webserver
oder sowas standardmäßig mit anbieten kann.
Oder zumindest eine abstrahierte Socket-API.
Gibt's nicht.
Soll wieder 35 Grad werden.
Boah, fuck.
So, egal.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.